foreign
[Music]
ES
box
[Music]
foreign
house
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
thank you
everyone say hi yeah
moments from now not about
will step into the Play Zone one of them
will walk away with thirty thousand
dollars and the spot in the five hundred
thousand dollar season final we are
ready under one minute now for Hikaru
and wow what a move I'll raise it look
at him he's biting his sweatshirt he
doesn't know what to do eight minutes
and 59 seconds beaten by one second
could you have swapped Queenstown
immediately
Magnus has had no struggles against a
car over the board he should be happy
we have a winner Magnus Carlson takes it
he wins the air things Monsters the very
first event he's training
oh
my God oh my God
oh and we see a reactions
Fabiano caruana resigns what an
Armageddon game by Hikaru
we have set ourselves up for a dream
final we will have a winner today at the
Chaska cup and it will either be well
number seven Fabiano caruana or the 18
year old Uzbek Phenom notibeg Abdus and
to guide us through the day in the
studio Grandmaster David Howell fide
Master James Canty let's go and Grandma
Sir Daniel nardetsky
James both players have been terrific
this event so far who do you pick as a
favorite to win today yeah favorite is
going to have to be Abdul Torah because
he has to be beaten twice he's already
very strong of course he may see the
Grand Final by beating Fabi he's gonna
have to be beaten twice so of course
he's definitely a favor
not a bag in the Winner's bracket
throughout Fabi has to do it not once
but twice today Daniel how does he make
it happen well first he's got to win the
first match and then he's got to win the
second one I just get obviously
notorbeck's form has been excellent but
so has fabby's he's just got to play
steady I mean he's won all of the
armageddon's that he's played so he's
performing really well under pressure
he's got to get lucky obviously Notre
back in his current form to be beaten
twice Tanya that will take a Herculean
effort we'll see if Fabby has it under
his sleeve uh
doesn't have to look too far for
inspiration because the kind of trust
that we saw from him yesterday was
absolutely incredible David what did you
think of his farm Fabi was good
yesterday but there were one or two
shaky moments he had to progress in
Armageddon in both of his matches so
Fabi looks fantastic he looks great but
he needs to hit an even higher level
today to take down Abdus
what a big match this is going to be and
Fabiano caruana had some big moves that
he played on day four and this day
started with the loser semi-finals Sabi
and Jules musad fighting it out to make
it through to the losers final
feels like a masterclass from Fabi this
is strategic dominance this is just a
strategically winning position no
tactics nothing flashing it's old
Manchester's I like to say just slowly
accumulate the small positional
advantages and they tend to count later
on
it's domination here again look at these
Bishops this bishop is coming into E5
this black king is going to get mated
yes you have a point but it shouldn't be
quick enough this is game over Jose does
resign Fabiana Karana playing a
positional Masterpiece
panicking rookie two no you can't play
it 96.
[Music]
made on F6 drop the king back white king
is super safe I know since 97. oh my
goodness unbelievable these nights
oh my goodness
he reacts he did the impossible I love
this move by Fabi ambitious play keeping
that a pawn and that's a super dangerous
sponsor for black dragon this one is a
clean win from Fabi if he's able to
convert yeah this is just a master class
in not allowing the opponent any
activity any contemplate at all
beautiful that's going to end it
officially that's it
thanks so much against Jordan one person
you can't see the relief on of fabi's
face it's been a long day in the office
for the American Grandmaster
we started with eight top Grand Masters
At The Chess get Cup on day two it was
the end of the road for Hikaru Nakamura
and Alexander shimanov nor the back of
the satrov has continued his run
throughout in the Winner's bracket
meanwhile Jules musad Kolar is Dimitri
Oliver and Jordan van forest all knocked
out in the losers brackets setting
ourselves up for a Grand Final between
not the back and Fabiano caruana it is
truly a dream final I have to ask you
James we saw Fabi grinding it out
yesterday in the loser's bracket while
nordeback got to enjoy a free day will
fatigue be a factor yeah fatigue is not
going to be a factor for Fabi of course
he does this he plays long hours of
course he plays in the title Tuesday
sometimes both of them he's doing his
thing he's also working out a lot which
is very important for of course your
chest as well which he believes so I
think he's uh he's good and rest
and after that long day of
their final graciously joined us for an
interview where he to my surprise
mentioned that he considers himself an
underdog today
yeah I mean considering he has has two
lives I I guess I I am an underdog in
this match uh
but if I if I get past the first one I
do feel like there's some psychological
Edge going going into the second one but
uh of course I mean he he has two lives
and he's been showing super consistent
chess it's going to be
really really tough and I would be uh
I mean I would be lying if I said I I
definitely don't I that I don't feel
like a bit of an underdog uh to to win
two matches against him but I'll try my
best and I'm very happy to be here in
the final
the players have to play their best
chest today and if you have been
inspired and want to improve your chest
performance and things is here to help
one of the ways to do it is to make sure
that you have great air quality and you
can send us our your best photos of
watching The Chess kit cup to get a
chance at winning the soup is Sleek uh
things black wave plus device use the
hashtag chess Champs and at the end of
the show we will be announcing over now
we can't wait to see your selfies so
send them to us and also we can't wait
to get the chess action started it's not
just division one but the other two
divisions as well it is the Grand Final
and as always in the studio Grand Master
Simon Williams big day ahead of us
massive day it's the last day this is
what everyone's been looking forward to
the crescendo of the whole competition
and obviously we've got the big
encounter in division one but division
two and division three are very exciting
as well let's have a little look I think
at division two yeah
yeah a big Grand Final coming up in
division two the win fellowship and
sharp and Simon in percentage term who
do you hold as a favorite
well I think if it was one match this
would be a very close and very exciting
match because you got fedesv the big
fish who specializes in online play he
does very well in title Tuesday and all
the competitions on chess.com but then
you've got the shack monster the
destroyer of Kings I'm just going for
that Game of Thrones kind of like you
know acting role at the moment and this
guy is good he's really good I mean he's
been one of the best players in well
well number two he loves attacking if he
gets the kind of position where he can
attack he could well win this match but
he needs to win it twice fedexv has won
all of his matches so far so he's in the
winners bracket so he's definitely
favorite fedexv but mama jarov got to
come with the attack to try and level it
out
all the shock plays his kind of Chess
we're all gonna love it not just on the
studio but of course our chat as well
because it means fireworks on the board
now a fellowship has been in the windows
bracket throughout shock Rising Like a
Phoenix from the losers bracket what
does he do to take down one of the most
on-form players in the circuit well
you're right I mean feathersev is just
so good at online chess this is where he
specializes mamacharov has even said in
the past that he's not so good with the
mouse I understand that totally but
mamajarov is one of the most imaginative
attackers that the chess world has ever
seen so Mama jar has just got to get the
right positions he's got to get
positions which are messy which he can
attack in and which he can enjoy playing
and if he gets those kind of positions
he could well win this match but I think
whatever happens it's going to be very
exciting tactical Affair and we'll keep
you up to date with everything that
happens and let's remember the winner of
this division goes through to division
one and they win ten thousand dollars
which is not too shabby yeah absolutely
it is big bucks but that golden ticket
to division one of the next Champions
Chester event and there's also a grand
match in division three the reason day
time yeah yeah division three and you
can see here it's on again if you've
been following this tour each day you'll
know that Harry Krishna from India has
already played against Alan picho of
Argentina and Alan won that encounter
earlier on so Alan has made his way all
the way through to the Grand Final and
has to be the favorite because he's got
that chance where he can lose the first
match and then he gets a double chance
but Harry Krishna is back facing him
again in their last encounter Harry
Krishna actually blundered a piece in
the opening before move 10. Harry
Krishna never does that he's a legend
you know him very well I'm sure Tanya
yeah that's a soccer and his openings
are one of his biggest strands while the
players have to bring in their best
openings today it is a day a day for
them to avenge the losses that they've
had
because in division one we've got also a
big grudge match take a look at what
happened when not back up to satrov and
Fabiano caruana played each other two
days ago
oh poor Fabi here just struggling to
survive the next few moves so accurate
it's crazy Knight C6 it's on the board
he gives up his Knight and this is he
resigns and naughty back up to such a
takes the lead in his match you know
you're probably crashing to defeat for
uh by update and he just needs to try
and give Fabby some practical problems
whoa we're gonna have to relax big fella
what does that mean what desperation
here he's trying to block the white
rocks path to that g-pawn but
that should be a rezzy
did take some
take some looking good for white I've
got to say and Fabi just wrecking his
position fabi's fighting uh spirit here
has been uh diminished unfortunately no
way to keep this one going two pawns
down no harm to play he's about to win a
third fine that might trigger
resignation
Black Knight no good squares for it to
use and I think Fabi you can tell body
language there he leaned back has he
resigned he has Abdus takes the match
and that is their head to head the last
time they played in the best of four not
the back of the soundtrack of coming on
top so Fabiano caruana is playing for
Revenge today the Grand Final and we see
it is a very close head-to-head between
these two David two days ago that much
up to satrov took it in four games but
it felt smooth it might have felt smooth
but there was one game where Fabi was
able to outplay him was able to out
overpower uh Abdul sotorov that was
Abdus only defeats so far in the
tournament in an individual game so Fabi
knows he's capable he's slightly ahead
in the head-to-head scores there
but he needs to bring it in two matches
today it's an uphill struggle he
mentioned as well he's not sure of his
chances and how difficult is that to
deal with psychologically knowing that
you have to beat your opponent twice in
one day it was definitely difficult and
if we let it get to you you will it
it'll Crush you right you could lose
immediately before the game even starts
they say it starts in the mind Jedi it
starts in the mind so you have to
definitely take it one game one match at
a time is down you said earlier
wow it could either be a short day of
dear she could be here for while and we
could have a long day of transaction
because take a look at the Grand Final
format that's coming up the players will
first fight in a best of four rapid
games 15 minutes with a three second
increment if not a back wins he is the
champion Fabiano caruana if he takes
that match then there will be a grand
final reset which will have a best of
two for the rapid games and of course if
there's a tie we will go into the
bidding Armageddon Daniel what are the
chances of us experiencing another wild
Armageddon very high actually higher
than they've been really in any match I
thought we would get zero arm against
yesterday we got two so this tournament
as a whole has been anything but
predictable but obviously two players
who are this evenly matched in at least
one of the matches if Abby wins the
first they're even likelier to go into
the Armageddon in the second one because
they're just gonna have two games Tanya
but we'll cross that bridge when we get
there wow it is going to be a fun day of
chess for all of us here watching and
commentating but for the players it's
going to be a big fight because on the
line so much the winner wins a thirty
thousand dollars a spot in the season
final and also goes back with a digital
Champions chest or Trophy and uh this
comes in two editions one goes to the
winner and there is also a very special
Fan Edition you can go bid for your
chess kit Cup trophy on chess champs.io
it comes with a very special VIP ticket
to the in-person season final Magnus
Carlson has already punched his ticket
and today we will have the third player
who will make it two That season a final
and we're all getting ready and excited
as the clocks are ticking for the games
to begin and David for not a backup
disaster of having that rest day what
kind of openings has he prepared
according to you well I think he's going
to just stick to his style the way he
beat Fabi earlier in the event was with
some very classical openings normally a
spin on for example the Catalan or a
kind of Queen's horn openings I do want
to mention though having a rest day for
me is not necessarily a good thing you
lose your momentum sometimes you get out
of the Rhythm so I'm just a tour of he
will have wanted to spend yesterday
studying chess even if he had some time
off and there we go it is another
Queen's Pawn opening which line will he
go for do you think probably is going to
come better prepared this time Daniel
probably is and big question now what is
not about going to play he's shown an
affinity for the Catalan this time he
goes with the two knights and we have a
rogozin and opening that Fabi I mean you
have to know this opening well if you
were to cross 2750 it's like a rite of
passage whoa Bishop D2 what
he's just gone back he's moved the
bishop twice in a row he's given black a
free move what is this hold my beer
somewhere Mr H3 dingly rhyme this is
what not a back was doing on his uh free
day on his rest day preparing this well
I'll tell you what Fabi has done he's
back with the exact same sweatshirt that
he was wearing yesterday is that
superstitious lucky Fabi you know what
in a way it can be sometimes it is or
sometimes you're just like this is this
makes me comfortable right I actually
have one that I gave away because I lost
two games in it and I was like you know
what stupid sweatshirt I don't even want
to wear this it's 81 degrees in his room
and he's wearing a sweatshirt that guy
is a Madman even by my standards and I
like it really warm wow Fabi 27 degrees
I apologize I forgot where I am Celsius
still in Oslo still a bit warm and the
CO2 level was a bit High there where
Fabius meanwhile white has lost a move
we mentioned the white Bishop came out
and kind of uh just retreated head hung
in shame there but black has gained a
move the point to H6 and Fabi know how
he's delaying castling the black king
doesn't necessarily want to commit
itself yet to the king side because I
think I'll do Satora might have ideas of
throwing pawns forward on that flank
he's essentially created what we call a
hook by forcing blacks Pawn forward to
H6 and later white can maybe use that
pawn as a way to wrench open lines and
okay we're about to find out G4 come on
G1 H3 don't you move your light squared
Bishop because that would mean that
Notre back that his novelty was akin to
dingley renza H3 because when he played
it I was commentating I thought ding is
preparing G4 let's go get it right nah
he was just trying to stall and move wow
didn't turn out very well for him did it
this is the moment of truth wow so I've
decidorah can choose two different
strategies here the solid approach just
develop White's light squared Bishop try
to Castle the white king it's going to
just be very balanced there or you go
straight for the attack forget about the
white king go for the black King James I
know which one you want to see yeah I'm
just gonna play G4 and just hold for a
bit now of course you actually have to
calculate something every G4 is nice oh
my goodness it's so fun to play moves
like that G4 obviously Knight takes Rook
G1 and then he might play F5 or bring
the Knight back the problem is the dark
Square Bishop is locked in of course we
would like to take on H6 with the bishop
but it's not possible we also would like
the castle Queen side that's not
possible either so we might as well just
develop pieces here Bishop D3 you know
abdulsutor off Style Just develop Bishop
D3 castle kingside and then maybe play
for E4 or whatever position gives us
later
yeah he might go for a queen move as
well just to kind of maintain the
tension if White's light Square Bishop
comes out too soon it might be forced to
move again over the next few turns you
don't want to lose too much more time if
you're up to sator often he was the one
who elected this uh kind of strange
funny looking variation losing a move
with white but now he's the one pausing
as well spending two minutes in the tank
here well it was really hard to predict
the move short Castle I know that's a
very unexpected move by Fabi really
throwing a wrench into the opening
preparation but we have talked about
this sometimes when you over rely on the
engine suggestions you can actually miss
very natural moves and your view of the
position can get distorted to where you
think oh you know something like a7a5
that's totally natural because it's the
engine's top line or norderbeck just
prepared two different systems maybe he
looked at Rogue G1 or G4 maybe he also
looked at Bishop D3 and he's just trying
to weigh these options but that's less
likely given how much time he spent
Tanya and he finally elects Bishop D3
boo
Bishop D3 on the board by not a bad we
still might be seeing the Jeep on
Advanced on the boat intentionally
provoking Fabi to make that h-pawn move
so that it can become a hook for a
potential kingside attack in these
openings very often for white you delay
the development of the light Squad
Bishop because you don't want to waste a
Tempo if and when black captures the
central pawns now fabi's in a thing and
what chat you don't want to waste is the
opportunity to send us your selfies
because you could win the air things
device we will be revealing the best
photos show us your best photo of
watching The Chess kid cup and we'll
bring it up on the show right now David
Bishop D3 is there still hope for a
potential Rook G1 G4 yes that being said
Fabi is retreating now and getting ready
to strike in the center uh fabi's last
move he's it looks a bit odd as well
Black's Bishop came out then retreated
and Fabi just wants to throw Pawns open
in the center black has castled black is
slightly ahead there and uh Daniel I saw
out of the corner of my eye a bit of a
kind of frown from you after this last
night it's been fashioned both sides
have waisted a Tempo and we've sort of
transposed to a type of semi-slav not
exactly shall we say we semi-transposed
uh to a semi slav and Fabi is playing
regular semi-slav moves B6 and Bishop B7
and often black strikes actually not
with E5 but with C5 the reason Notre
break played B3 is to discourage the
very typical idea that Tanya mentioned
which involves taking on C4 and then
pushing E5 you can still take on C4 but
then you're giving up a large share of
the center so I think Fabi is more
likely going to orient his play around
C5 he doesn't have to play it
immediately he can play Rook C8 he can
play Queen E7 it's a pretty quiet
position
pretty quiet position and I've just
tutorial for reacts by moving his Queen
out I completely agree I think black is
going to keep this keep the tension in
the center now but it's about who
strikes first in the middle of the board
for example if black does line up The
Rook with the White Queen maybe now
white will take the opportunity to step
forward and uh chaos could be Unleashed
here black could offer quite likely here
step forward himself you could capture a
pawn before challenging the center a bit
later on he keeps attention with this
Rook he's definitely going for E5 it
feels like with this last Rook slide and
uh yeah it's just so tense I never know
when to pull the trigger when to step
forward or wait for the opponent it's
sir just kind of a guessing game right
now they're tiptoeing against around
each other just staring each other down
what do we think here is he gonna push
his Central Pawn First is white going to
be the first one to strike and try to
gain extra space in the middle of the
board either they said no they were
rookie one I was actually looking at E4
and maybe E5 that's really wild there E4
E5 and like all that tension there in
the center is like ridiculous can you
hear me out of here you know I mean
that's the stuff you don't want to see
right it's just very hard sometimes to
play those type of positions but rookie
won I guess he might be meeting E5 with
E4 it is possible that's a crazy line
like let's actually E5 E4 let's take a
look at that David what happens there E5
E4 there's just too much tension just
aesthetically I want to play C5 with
black but it really doesn't quite work
C5 unbelievable Everybody Plays B4 never
seen a structure like this before yeah
wow evaluation bar is not impressed
there for black I guess the idea would
be to capture in the center here and if
the white knight takes at the very
minimum black could just trade off
everything in the middle of the board
and probably isn't doing too badly maybe
this there are some tricks I'm looking
in this direction but uh either way
complicated stuff he's chosen something
else here Fabi he's traded pawns on the
C4 square and now I'm guessing he wants
to push this Pawn forward to open up his
Bishop along the diagonal watch out for
this Knight being captured and White's
Pawn structure being shattered a bit
later on I like this a lot because
Bishop takes F3 is not such an easy
threat to Perry you might have to move
your queen back to D1 your Bishop back
to E2 maybe I'm influenced by that evil
bar but I'm just not all that impressed
of the way another back has positioned
his pieces he might have to go Knight E4
and start bailing out and trading some
pieces but he might end up with some
weaknesses in the center when all of the
Smoke Clears yeah feels like white is
the one with questions to answer here
don't like the way this opening is
turned out for objector of feels like
Fabi solved all his problems uh actually
it's white here who needs to be very
careful
strange decision to go for this opening
I think the experiment with the bishop
Retreat earlier it's just been fired
I fight at the Sally station 94 you
called it on the board just trying to
trade pieces but you're just trying to
trade here to equalize with white
nothing more than that
so most modern day Novelties go
is already trying to fight for equality
here that's
quite a surprise out of the opening yeah
I mean Bishop G5 Bishop D2 I thought if
he had gone Rook G1 and G4 maybe he's
saving that for Norway chess remember he
has a tournament to play so he's not
necessarily bringing his A-game in the
opening
I don't think the black is much better
or anything like that I think fabi's
Advantage is still very modest but like
David said noterberg has the tiptoe very
carefully the next five six moves I
think he should be able to hold his own
here though
and having this big tournament coming up
Norwich as it's an OTB event over the
board but you also have this Grand Final
right you are looking for a ticket into
the season final how do you sort of
balance that in reserving maybe some of
your prep for the big games at Norwich s
but also this one probably a really big
moment for our naughty back absolutely I
mean being versatile of course as you
see a universal I mean Notre bag plays
C4 he's by D4 Sometimes some Knight F3
there so you sometimes you just don't
know and as you see at the higher level
especially if you check I really like to
check top players games in their
repertoires and as you see over time
they become more Universal Players which
goes back to a quote that Fabi said that
I actually use all the time most of the
top players are Universal but what
separation is the calculation right huge
part so of course I think he has some
prep for that too as well you never know
because uh they stay Universal
calculation over everything you
mentioned Universal we're seeing trades
here and they were talking about the
styles of these two players it just
feels that both of them are very
Universal they can play any kind of
positions they find their dynamism and
is it fair to say that their styles are
quite similar to each other
possibly they certainly don't have too
many weaknesses in their game and of
course Fabi one of his main strengths
opening preparation calculation
um Abdus I think what's so impressive
about him is that at such a young age
he's still great in the end game he's
still great in slower positions how do
you target players like this uh often
when I study top players or when I uh
study my future opponents I'm looking
okay where can I find holes in their
game against Abdus tour
the answer is no you just don't find any
holes so that's why it's hard for Fabi
and these games will be decided by tiny
little margins tiny little errors here
and there
yeah hard to predict and maybe time
scrambles will be decisive in this one
nerves yeah but his nerves are held up
throughout the entire event here and I
just want to say as well fabi's last
move I really really like fighting in
the center White's Queen is going to get
kicked back in the near future by
Black's Rook or by the Black Knight and
yeah white has some big decisions to
make strategically uh I think actually
some uh really difficult uh horrible
decisions to make because you're going
to end up with a bad Pawn structure
excellent move I'm on board very
instructive move a lot of players would
reject this out of hand because of the
fear of allowing a protected passer why
does D5 but Notre back has seen one step
further calculation over everything
Knight comes out to F6 kicks the queen
out of E4 the queen is replaced by a
pawn once it moves back black play Z4
the Knight has nowhere to go it has to
uh Journey to the edge of the board
where black and play Queen D7 and then
pick that Knight off with G5 this is not
an option outerbeck might be close to
lost in this position and so he's
elected to meet fire with fire Queen
drops into C6 and we're gonna get some
tactics here or we're gonna get a trade
of Queens if Fabio plays Queen C7
yeah I guess he doesn't want to this is
like a last resort trading the Queens
off because white might find some safety
there doesn't look too bad to me uh
swapping the Queens off the other option
maybe just defending this bishop with
the Queen the other direction how does
white meet this one still the same
threat of pushing this Pawn trapping
this Knight now spicy spicy it is yeah
do you have to maybe just trade
everything off of your abducator off and
hope that you're not suffering too much
in a position like this one
feels really Pleasant for black to be
honest white has isolated pawns over on
this side of the board black has some
tactical ideas against the white king
maybe on this vulnerable Square
temporarily this bishop undefended
yeah I think I would keep the Queens on
how about you guys
yeah definitely want to keep the Queens
on here and if you want to keep the
Queens on if I'm black I mean I
definitely have the initiative it's just
a practically engine's like yeah
everything's ego it always is equal
everything is always equal but it's
always a practical chances I'm playing a
human here so I'm playing Abdul Tora and
I want to keep these Queens on the board
because your pieces are kind of weird
here the bishop on D2 is kind of strange
E4 is coming the Knight has no squares
Queen E7 definitely makes some sense but
we do I think he's just gonna trade
everything off right we only have a
choice of Queen C7 or E7 is that like a
bishop C7 like what does that do Bishop
C7
yeah makes some sense as well definitely
yeah it's playable opening this one up
maybe hitting the White Queen a bit
later on either way lots of tempting
options for Fabi and uh he's in the tank
now just pondering how to proceed he
knows that he's definitely not in any
trouble is black he's the one putting
the pressure on so he's just kind of
weighing up what's going to cause Abdul
sotorov uh the most stress in this type
of position he does choose to keep the
Queens on nice
and look at that we've got our first
photo of the day in and sending us how
you guys are watching the chess kit cup
keep them coming and we will pick the
best photo and you will win and add
things device so you can monitor the air
quality to improve your chest
performance and so far in this matchup
it looks like Fabiano caruana is so
ready for the fight with the black
pieces without any trouble at all he has
equalized out of the opening and the
pressure is on not a back but a big
decision there by Fabi to play E4 and
fix the center what do you do you
approve of that it's hard to say I mean
E4 isn't as strong as it would be when
the Knight had to go to H4 now we can
drop back to D2 so the point isn't to
Target the Knight I think Fabi is
actually thinking uh in rather violent
terms about a potential kingside assault
with Queen to H4 because white doesn't
have a lot of pieces on the king side
the queen H4 immediately drops the
Knight on D7 so that has to be factored
in maybe Knight D7 to F6 but it's a
positionally risky idea because you've
given up some control of the center hard
to say whether I like it David I'll ask
the highest rated player in the room I
don't know Dania I completely agree I
think he woke up and chose violence
because he has just played Knight F6 and
I'm just wondering I don't know if it
works the evaluation Bar's still in the
middle but for example if white pushes a
pawn can we go for this uh typical Greek
gift sacrifice uh here we call it the
Greek gift because you kind of lure the
opponent out the white king is forced
out and the evaluation bar still not
reacting just bang in the middle how can
this be equal uh here you check the
white King two options to go forward or
back if you Retreat I do fear for the
white King still
equal
feels like this is leading to Checkmate
but apparently white has enough maybe
after Knight F1 there is nothing it's
crazy wow yeah it looks like the white
king can't just hold on in the corner
and wipe her true yeah white saves the
day it's just gonna be a repetition of
moves no way to win this one but you
need nerves of Steel to even consider
allowing uh the black queen and Knight
into your Camp I think abductor of might
be inclined to just push a pawn forward
for example to stop the Black Knight
coming in but uh yeah either way
difficult decision right now huge threat
potentially at least in Practical terms
and there we go he does prevent that he
rules out all nonsense he pushes H3
but then once again that is upon move
and for all the chess kids out there
once you push a palm you can't take it
back this does invite Fabi to set up a
battery along the B8 H2 diagonal so
there are still attacking possibilities
with the bishop falling back all the way
next to that Rook on the queen side and
then the queen aligning up now that he
has very nicely developed the queen side
Rook is that a plan that could be that
could cause some trouble to White yeah
absolutely the only problem is that
white snake can drop back to F1 on
demand and defend the H2 square but when
you do that you also loosen your grip
over the C4 Pawn so black could actually
consider C takes D4 at some moment when
the Knight has dropped back of course
the queen and A4 also protects the C4
upon so yeah the jury is really still
out on whether this attack is successful
I'm a little bit skeptical I'm going to
be honest I feel like black might just
not have enough material to make
tangible things happen but I mean that
remains to be seen the email bar is
still in moderate approval approval
rating at like 40 percent
yeah it's just really hard do you commit
to that King side attack wow Fabi kind
of contorting himself here recruiting
the Black Knight maybe aiming to come
forward and go going for some sacrifice
later on he's opened up the diagonal for
the queen to get towards the white king
yeah I think he's going for that attack
he really wants to strike now and uh
force that reset later in the day we
could be uh in for a long day if Abby
does Checkmate the white king in this
game very fancy I mean he might even
start with Queen H4 first then Knight G5
too as well I mean just to put the queen
in positioning to be ready to sacrifice
and then follow up with Queen H3 with a
very nasty mating idea of course the
Knight can swing to F1 but then in that
case we have Rook E6 over to G6 because
everything's just opened up they're
pretty nasty stuff there Queen H4 Knight
G5 sack rookie six and you could be
mated very fast there there's not a lot
of pieces for white on the king size so
definitely I see this nasty little
attack that Fabian was trying to cook up
here with his fancy move Knight H7
James with some interesting attacking
possibilities that could appear in the
next couple of moves I have to say
throughout this chess kit cup we have
been seeing this very direct approach by
Fabi as you mentioned David waking up
and choosing violence is this a Fabi 2.0
that we're seeing over the last couple
of months I think yes he's figured out
that that is the recipe for Success at
the top level in Rapid and Blitz chess
especially we do say it's a cliche it's
kind of easier to attack than defend and
when the clock is ticking when you only
have five six minutes left it's
definitely easier to go for the
opponent's king kind of one track bind
rather than find these really difficult
uh defensive moves that actually often
here for example are just impossible to
find and do the sword has pushed forward
he's in that mood though he's in that
zone and it's brought him success why
not go for the king maybe he's realized
that that's the one thing Abdul Satora
doesn't like he doesn't like to be
attacked I don't think anyone does to be
honest but I love being attacked speak
for yourself man right but uh wow
pushing pawns now F5 and we're live we
have five and we live oh for sure he's
very aggressive right now you can feel
the tension you might even see me as a
crazy move but G5 G4 too is really what
he wants Knight F5 I mean Knight F1 now
F4 maybe not I mean it has to be correct
so maybe Queen H4 first Rook f8 yeah
he's definitely pushing F4 he's just all
out Fabi 2.0 today hunt on yeah he's the
man woke up and chose violence today he
is very aggressive this is a fiber you
don't see all the time but it's a Bobby
we'd love to see all the time this is
some amazing chess that we're seeing
naughty back up the satrobe in big
pressure with the white pieces head and
hands he's got to be feeling the heat
right now yeah and he's got nothing
going on on the queen side that's the
thing Fabi might have to abandon the
queen side because the queen will
ultimately have to get involved or not
he's just gone recap seven which is a
multi-purpose move the obvious intention
is to double on the FL and do that F4
push and make it as strong as possible
but there's a more hidden intention
which is that when he moves the Queen
the A7 Pawn won't even be hanging so
there's just emptiness on the queen side
for Notre back his Pawn on D5 Tanya
looks impressive but it's completely
blockaded by the bishop I'm liking what
I'm seeing here from Paddy but the hard
work of actually attacking remains to be
done this is the prep phase when
everything's calm
yeah it's as if the board is kind of cut
in half here white has the pawn uh on D5
the protected passport he has more space
if you think about the queen side of
this side of the board but nothing to do
on that flank instead it's the other
side from where White's pieces really
can't kind of cross over this White
Queen would love to be over here
somewhere on the king side takes a few
moves to do that though and huge threats
already James you mentioned some Pawn
storms throwing these pawns down the
board you could certainly Imagine The
Black Queen appearing this Pawn comes to
kick away this White Knight
I just don't see anything productive to
do for white and if there's no plan
you're going to be in the tank for a
long time you're going to be struggling
reacting in chess is the hardest thing
you're just giving your opponent all the
fun and there we go the White Queen was
too far offside not doing anything so
she's uh rerouting herself and yeah
I mean back into the action
but she's beaten to it by The Black
Queen yeah I knew that move was coming I
mean I was like Queen D1 is that for
Queen H5 after Queen H4 but that fails
immediately the bishop G3 so Queen H4 is
a very strong move you have to either
move the Knight King H2 come on now what
are you doing King H2 does not make any
sense Knight H1 we saw that yesterday so
it's the one probably not the bishop
takes G3 is happening maybe he might
just give the pawn up yeah that's what
you're thinking but he might not take it
fabby's next move might not even be
Bishop takes G3 it might actually be
Knight G5 followed by F4 I'm struggling
to figure out any sort of defensive
construction James yeah this queen H5
Bishop takes G3 line super important
otherwise Black's Queen would have been
kicked out of the attack
Yep this would win a piece for black the
night would drop because the White Queen
would be undefended and yeah nothing
else to do I don't see any moves here if
you've Retreat us uh you mentioned there
James to any other Square then
bank there's going to be a sacrifice on
this Square things are going to open up
one of the black Brooks is going to
swing over this is going to end in
Checkmate it's almost guaranteed at this
point with so many attacking pieces for
black can we see the eval I mean not
even above the engine like what does the
engine do here what do they do let's
pull up the air probably some outlandish
move like Knight H5 that's exactly right
it always is not an H5 oh that actually
is the second move first move was Queen
E2 give up the pawn second is Knight H5
wow let's move this one but that does
nothing pretty much come on bro what is
that exactly yeah I guess the idea
behind Queen E2 is you're hoping uh as
you guys have been alluding to that
black expedient grabs this pawn and then
maybe you just offer a trade of queens
and you say okay I'm gonna Pawn down but
in an end game this might be a nice kind
of Ace card up my sleeve for later on
right but yeah that's incredibly hard
and just to show the other movement into
that Knight H5 Rook c2's mentioned
that's a nothing move not gonna happen
Knight H5 what is the plan though I
don't see it if I just kick you away I
don't really want to touch pawns on the
banana four maybe Knight F4 yeah and you
give up a pawn but you release a lot of
the pressure
and now maybe bishop two I don't know
still looks quite bad honestly like even
if black Chronicle cooperates that's a
bad sign like your opponent does what
you want him to do and it still sucks
wow I guess at least now you have a nice
open diagonal for your Bishop it looks
pretty Queen D4 would be nice
in D4 unfortunately
covered it's a difficult decision he's
down to three minutes I'll do satorov
what's he gonna find is he going to play
one of the moves recommended by the
computer
they aren't easy they aren't natural and
even those give black the advantage
ah Fabi he started like a man in form
just determined look at the focus on
Bobby's face I mean Focus Fabi you can
tell he's in the zone right he also
wants that Revenge too as well Rook C2
he played Rook C2 he found that one and
that was actually the third best move by
the engine but it does give up the pawn
uh you bring your Rook to the defense
where do you find your compensation if
Sabi gets greedy here well there isn't
even that much compensation you're just
happy that you're not getting mated in
the next five seconds but Notre break is
bracing for impact that's what his move
indicates he has abandoned you know he
has abandoned desires of Landing the
plane safely he is he knows the crash is
gonna happen he's just putting his hands
over his head and that's a very annoying
way of Defending Fabi has to time F4
correctly if you play it too soon and
your Center collapses this game is going
to turn around so it's far from over I
vote Knight G5 keep building it up
because Bishop takes G3 as David said
it's kind of in your pocket for later
yeah no rush often building up as well
it's the most annoying for the opponent
just keeping that tension especially if
the opponent is low on the time here
like abducator office keep the tension
keep asking them those difficult
questions if you take the White Knight
yes you've pocketed upon but actually
white split might become a bit easier at
least white has a past deep onto back on
white noise and end game might not that
be that bad for him so uh yeah just
confuse the opponent here keep the
tension pass the move back and a25 and
we live as uh as we always say I mean
that's just a nice move put the Knight
on G5 and there also are some
possibilities almost as a sacking on H3
right maybe doubling the Rooks you have
all the play here from black standpoint
and we're up a little bit of time
great chess kit point though right not
to get greedy but to play for for
creative and keeping the pressure on the
board so many of us would just rush to
pick up that night pick up that extra
Pawn but it's so much more difficult for
the opponent if you can keep the
position cramped for him and keep
building the pressure Fabi does exactly
that but with a different move Rook to
f8 Knight G5 in the pocket but it's uh
what you guys said not to give up that
strong Bishop on D6 just for a pawn
because it's way worth more than that it
blocks that D5 Pawn from going forward
ahead on the board and he's reaping the
rewards of it already Rook F1 not
approved of by the all-knowing Silicon
fiend is it because of Knight G5 what do
we think you know I also like this idea
of just yes what's the best piece for
white is the bishop so even in exchange
sacrifices is like Rook F6 at some point
giving it up taking back and just put
another piece on the fire which is Rook
G6 but of course that's extreme it's not
necessary but it's definitely possible
it tells you everything that is in his
position right now eval bar jumped after
Rook F1 guys what are we thinking here
what is the move I just can't
he's done it it's on the board but what
is the idea behind Abdul satoros play I
again just don't see any moves for
everything back
retreating looks like fish of random
chest now with all yours
is it time for F4 is it is it time yeah
four takes takes I mean F4 Rook F6 these
are very good moves and then you have to
figure out what to recapture with on F4
also a difficult question there's a case
to be made for rookout four Bishop even
Queen F4 loads up the battery and
threatens Queen takes G3 ideas so
yeah maybe it's disgusting yeah I mean
just Bishop takes feels nice I mean
you're threatening to take care the
white Rook is that's the same idea
except there's no Queen
he's breaking through
looks so beautiful for black everything
is perfectly positioned if you just
compare the activity of the pieces
White's pieces sad stuck at home is as
if they just forgot to wake up today
blacks pieces they're out they're fully
dressed they're ready to party and the
Breakthrough has happened and it's
happening powerfully now
can relate to the white pieces me too I
think any chess player can yeah so
taking is so bad then you know what else
do you do here in fact Knight H5 that
was the move from before but I mean it
feels like as a human here practically
you've got to get rid of that pawn you
see how the eval bar was almost you know
the the entire board was the eval bar
for black after we uh we looked at a
sample line after Pawn takes and it's
really bad for Abdus to draw up here as
he's getting lower on time too as well
this is like a 1-0 or 01 for fobby here
wow it's really starting to feel like
that if the Knight was to fall all the
way back to that square next to the king
we might be seeing some sacrifices
already with the Knight taking that H3
Pawn I think your absolutely right James
that white cannot let the F4 Pawn
survive for too long with all these
threats of a sack on H3 or the pawn
moving one step ahead to F3 this is
looking very bad and how smooth and
Flawless has Fabi made this look it's
like a symphony orchestra it's like you
know you bring all the instruments to
the king side the way that he's
coordinated his piece is really
beautiful every move played with
intention first Rook F7 then Queen H4
and there is a feeling of just total
dexterity when you watch these top
players handle attacks and pieces so
smooth and he plays F4 at the perfect
moment when all of the pieces are
involved in the attack this one seems to
be very close to being over you're
making it sound like poetry right now
the way it is played with the black
pieces every single piece on the board
and every Pawn doing its job is this uh
is this a sort of a one for the history
books to learn how to attack David yeah
textbook stuff
just for all the chess kids out there
yeah just look at this game in terms of
how to coordinate your pieces and yeah
this is the type type of game we rarely
see at the top level where it's just so
one-sided it's often oh I shouldn't say
this but it's the type of game you see
when it's a higher rated player versus a
low rated player one side is passive the
other side is the one doing all the work
improving their pieces but at least he's
got the Queen's off nice move there he's
gonna end up without any other pieces
after F take C3 though that's the
problem yeah that's the problem yeah F
takes E3 you just win I mean you can
also play F32 but FJ C3 is just material
grabbing some material but okay I guess
like though you're not getting made it
you know what I mean so I'm not getting
mated anymore but I will list some
material here at the very least
yeah but at least uh yeah that's step
one don't get checkmated okay Checkmate
that's the only way to have any chance
of winning the game by not getting
checked I don't know what he's playing
against F takes you through there is
Bishop C3 but then black can take on F2
and deflect the king with Bishop to H2
when winning in exchange so
I think Fabi is asking himself the same
thing maybe H4 by white to chase the
Knight away first but I don't see what
that changes even if the Knight
hibernates on H7 and Fabi he's come to
the same conclusions and H4 is the idea
but this doesn't change anything the
Knight has done its job wow F3 ugly
stuff but at least he's found an escape
Square for his night there's gonna be
two pawns down however at the very
minimum after Pawn takes Pawn simply on
this Square
Fabi doesn't need to rush this Pawn is
not going anywhere in the near future
there's still a pin along the F line
he's got that pass there though on D5
maybe he's pinning his hopes on that
sure also the time too as well means
under a minute here I mean honestly this
was a master class it was a crush
compared to two days ago this is a whole
different Lobby especially with the
black pieces too as well they say win
with white draw with black top level
chest but here he's looking like he's
about to win with black and then you're
gonna give me the white pieces and we're
looking you know this could be another
type of match here completely turned
around having to beat norterbeck twice
today if he wants to to win the whole
thing yeah and I said it before the game
started rest days they're the worst I
hate rest days just I think I went
through a two-year period where I always
performed barley after a rest day you
just lose all momentum and uh after the
tour of he was playing like a god in the
first uh section of this tournament Fabi
yesterday he stayed Matt Sharp he was
playing games he's still in the zone
it's just so incredibly hard to play
after a rest day it feels like he's lost
uh lost everything all the power he had
basically just from two days ago updates
a tour of this first game at least he
needs to just get it out of the system
he's crashing to defeat here it's still
a long way to go but not an auspicious
start
that is so interesting uh do you guys
agree that having that rest day when
you've got this great form going you've
got the momentum in the tournament we've
seen the way not a back has been
performing he's the one who actually
knocked down uh Fabiano caruana to the
losers bracket and then you get this
free day which to us might feel great
you've got the opportunity to prepare
but does that also hamper your momentum
in the tournament yeah it depends how
you're doing when you're losing a lot of
games it's great to get a rest day even
if you don't feel like having a recipe
if you like I want to play again but
you're actually tilting and you're
losing a lot of games when you're
playing extremely well I agree
completely with David you want to sit
down and play you're playing well you
know it's everything's happening and
then suddenly that break in momentum it
can really hurt you notabeck's still
trying here but Fabi I think has enough
time and enough technique to put this
one home
two pawns up a little bit of extra time
on the clock it should
should be a matter of technique as they
say I hate that phrase but I just used
it there and he just needs to make sure
that somehow he gets his Knight into the
game again for black he needs to make
sure that at least one of his extra
pawns survives and he also wants to
ensure that White Pass deep on you've
alluded to a few times there Daniel it
doesn't at least cause some distraction
a bit later on pushing now bypassing the
White Knight I loved it I loved it
because King G2 was super annoying I was
like yo King G2 is so annoying yeah it
is very annoying
exactly you wanted to play G6 but now
he's got a G4 that was the whole idea of
G5 very strong from Fabi right saying
what did you want to play oh you want to
play King G2 if I play G6 you go King G2
then you move the Knight back I go G5
when you play King G2 I play G4 as we
see on the board very strong from Fabi
but gotta move a little bit faster here
and of course when the time gets low as
we've seen before with that game with
her mussar Jewels he was winning right
things were fine got a long time and it
collapsed completely so he is getting in
that territory the players are playing
on seconds amazing chess but they've
burnt clock while getting there and now
the E3 Pawn is on the fire you could
jump with that Knight to the edge of the
board but the white truck will pick up
the E3 Pawn this is uh yeah but you win
a piece there I think Knight fortnite H3
and Rook F2 and Fabby has to see that if
he sees it he wins does he see that
Knight H5 wins I think it wins a piece
20 seconds all right will he play it
same amount of time not each fifth it's
still not over even he's gonna win this
night on F1 and motorbike's gonna send
his deep on down the board it's
happening as we speak Daniel Knight H3
check you can give a check with the Rook
you can win that night but white does
pick up a bunch of Pawns the players are
playing on seconds now you're up a piece
but that Knight is far away from Play
The Deep Pawn is advancing how G4 is
this tough or is this easy for Fabi to
convert the good thing is he doesn't
have too much Choice the Black Knight
now is stranded but it only has two
squares to come back to he finds it but
D6 might lose the knife Abby might be
trying to give it away for the d-pawn
but that ensuing Rook end game isn't as
easy as I think Fabby thinks it is yeah
practical this is stuff he was just in
this situation with Jules the two nights
in the rug trying to figure it out
trying to be accurate oh snap I'm in
time trouble I lose right now here okay
losing is a hard one it's gonna be very
hard to lose the zoo light I mean with
black but of course uh winning is
definitely difficult with look at this
under 10 seconds now King F7 it's seven
another back has to make a move and five
it's a night baby and now we're in a
working game where it might be equal
whoa
yeah but what does Notre but do because
Rook is coming to D4 this is actually
almost impossible to defend let's see if
notrebed can pull off the unimaginable
and he is so far making All the Right
Moves attacking the A7 Pawn that we've
forgotten about since the middle game
spotting counter play going active with
the white Rook finding Targets this
might be an objective draw now yeah
that's gonna be a hard psych blow that's
gonna be a hard psychology but now of
course you know win with white drama
black hey if I draw it is what it is I
didn't lose but man I was Winnie you
know what I mean that's still not easy
for white because Rook B5 is met with C4
and there's a skewer on the fifth rank
oh we cute
the other one and he's chasing the the
queen side pawns using the threat of
Checkmate to win Tempe amazing defense
beautiful defense yeah he's gonna hold
she's gonna check and takes and we have
a draw here guys we have a draw on our
hands
is the one who's got last time on the
clock losing upon after another Pawn A4
March is down but this one will end in a
draw is this one one of the biggest
turnarounds that we've seen close very
cool I mean yeah we're just gonna have
to say yes to that like norterbeck was
definitely losing the position was gross
I mean imagine with the queen on H4 and
a Pawn on F4 how did you get out of this
right he was down he was down a piece
correct still tricky is Fabiano
threading Rook G6 and Rook G5 the one
thing that would kill white right now is
verook trade avoid that like the plague
and Notre back
go forward King D7 is forced but that's
a complication because black can step up
with his King and there's still some
work to do come on Danny oh but that's a
buzz skill
now you're gonna give a check drive the
king to the edge of the board
repetition coming up this guy doesn't
miss yeah oh that's actually a pretty
repetition that we're gonna see now sick
look at this draw
ERS right yeah
nowhere for the black king to hide and
game is about to be drawn wow I wrote
him off too soon I cursed Fabi there I
jinxed Fabby what a safe by Abdul
sotorov
that would be so mad I'm not even gonna
lie it's hard not to be mad at a game
like that if you're fobby really you
have to really get over that fast get to
the next game because if you don't it
can affect the next one now he knows how
the Miami Heat are feeling he was so mad
he didn't sit even for a second just
left the screen as we saw there Fabiano
caruana completely winning a Flawless
game played by him in round one but you
gave a player like not about just one
chance and that's all it took active
defense from him some amazing
resourceful play in that end game David
where did it all go wrong for Fabi well
Fabi as we mentioned had it in the bag
he won material he had that huge attack
earlier he cashed in but his conversion
technique was not precise and it was
here he I think he played the most
natural move on the board Knight back to
F4 it looks good but the problem is now
you cannot stop this Pawn without giving
back your night the king now is in
contact with this Knight the black Rook
is torn into mines cannot go after the
white Pawn without dropping the piece
instead if he had maybe had a bit more
time on his clock he would have for sure
played Knight to F2 check gaining time
using the technique of check and uh no
matter where the white king goes you can
maybe get your knight out of the way
with gain of time and later your black
king will be able to step across all the
blackrook will be able to go back to
stop this white Pawn black with an extra
Knight would most likely have won this
game
what a game this was by both players
Fabi absolutely amazing at the start and
it could have been a brilliant finish a
textbook finish but it wasn't to be not
a back up to such ROV he did bounce back
and managed to equalize that game it
starts with a level match score and they
will be playing three more rapid games
this has really set the tone for what
the day is going to be like and we are
going to go into a short break but it's
clear you don't want to go anywhere get
your popcorn ready it's going to be a
fun day of chess
[Music]
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest muscles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids chess kit is
easy whether you're a parent helping
your child a coach managing dozens of
kids or a school of hundreds signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
for over 75 years we've witnessed
moments that will last forever
records and trophies first and only game
changing Innovations from the heroes we
admire to the joy of watching them play
our history defines us inspires us and
pushes us into the future
celebrating 75 years of changing the
game
Puma forever faster
foreign
[Music]
this Monday May 29th we kick off
coverage of Norway chess 2023. this
event brings 10 elite players together
for 10 days of top level chess including
four names from division one of the
chess kid cup farouza Nakamura karawana
and Abdul satoroff they are joined by
Magnus Carlson among others as always
catch live cameras commentary and
interviews right here at twitch.tv chess
tune in this Monday for the kickoff an
aerofocus concentration performance
air things put you in control of air
pollutants that cloud your work from
home space shifting your state with
every breath
find your air of clarity now
obviously
uh we are loving the chess and we're
loving the Selfies that you have been
sending us in watching the chess kit cup
keep them coming because you could win
and air things with plus device to
monitor your air quality so that you can
also play some inspired chests like
we've been seeing in the chess kit cup
James do you have any advice for
everyone who's watching uh some uh
you've got a very strong IG game yeah
how can they win this guys just be
yourself okay and actually take some
extravagant pictures all right don't do
nothing crazy we don't want you hanging
on nothing hurting yourself at home this
is a family channel but at the same time
maybe you know have the dog which have
the baby with you have some friends
which you make funny faces and poses and
take that picture and we'll be waiting
for that one
a thrilling game one David the way it
ended was it perhaps a psychological
victory for Fabi the position that he
got with black well a psychological
Victory the first half of the game but a
huge blow the second half how it ended
if you can't win from that position a
whole night up Abby's going to start
doubting his belief to win the whole
match let alone a single game and uh
what tenacious play yes he was losing
for most of it but he made it hard for
Fabi finding some of those winning moves
that was extremely difficult and uh with
no time on the clock
yeah we can't blame Fabi too much just
great play from both sides and we're
into game two it's a Sicilian Defense I
haven't seen that one oh I mean I don't
know how many Sicilians have we seen
Tanya I think it might be close to zero
like maybe it is zero right this might
be the first one but of course
everybody's playing the anti-sicilians
like it's ridiculous Bishop B5 but okay
now be blank does have a position here I
mean pretty good so far so it's gonna be
fun though yeah and Fabi is a well-known
rosalimo expert the rosalimo variation
is denoted by Bishop B5 against Knight
C6 and interesting Notre back chooses a
relatively rare line compared to the
early G6 or E6 D6 is sort of third in
popularity but I've seen a lot of
players playing it recently online so
maybe the theory has gotten more
developed here
yeah and you mentioned he's a rosalimo
expert this variation of the Sicilian
was the kind of core of his opening
repertoire the world championship match
in 2018 against Magnus Carlson so this
is some World Championship prep we're
looking at in front of us uh Fabi for
sure has spent
countless hours looking at a position
like this one so white Bishop has done a
bit of a dance around the board it drops
back right now it's ready to advance in
the center White's deep Pawn in front of
the queen is going to step forward in
the next couple of turns and what does
abdulf have in mind there I like this
setup for white I've got to say it feels
like black is neglected developments the
black is still two or three moves away
from castling can white strike now
that's the question
it's a great question I mean D4 E5 D4
takes takes maybe Knight B4 but then I
go Bishop B3
and then there's some Shenanigans right
I'm thinking about that's all I think
about is what is the next trick Rook
takes C1 and 99 yeah it actually turns
out to be pretty good I think so that
might be Fabiano's reservation of
playing D4 he might also be considering
A4 there's other things that you can do
you can play D3 if you want to be more
modest but you're showing that idea
David you caught me with the word
Shenanigans I have to put it on the
board Rook takes Bishop uh I must have
been I would have missed this one I
would have blitzed into the position and
realized whoops I'm walking into a fork
it's of course not winning material for
black you sacrifice The Exchange to get
the exchange back but uh in this final
position you have to weigh up whether I
mean it still looks pretty scary for
black I've got to say with the king in
the center but you have to weigh up
whether you want to go for this uh Mass
series of Trades
interesting stuff I've got to say this
position is hard to evaluate fabby's
therefore wisely spending time right now
do you think he's going to go for it you
mentioned other Alternatives just
pushing one square kind of calm
conservative approach or this one yeah
as well and these are all Rue Lopez
ideas the position often resembles
certain lines of the real Lopez if white
plays D4 black often responds with E5
contesting the center in his own right
and here these positions I mean it's the
same ideas the same Pawn structure as
you would get in iru Lopez so black has
to be ready for that if he's going into
this line
now we've seen so many Royal Lopez
opening so many Spanish openings
anything but this you know put your Pawn
on E6 man
even when they start with the Sicilian
the most fighting opening out there they
somehow will walk the position back to
the Spanish crazy stuff well not yet
Fabby is still thinking all right but
looking likely at this point
Abby needs to decide on D4 Family come
on let's go let's go Scalia that's a
really long thing it's been about two
minutes straight out of the opening with
the white pieces it's one of the best
players in the world but especially with
the Russell limo this is uh fabi's bread
and butter and he does take a decision
with the Striking not in the center but
on the flank with the A4 so still
keeping it flexible where he wants to
push the Deep on and when he wants to do
it
yep he's trying to develop that white
rook in the corner which often takes too
long to develop across the board he's
just trying to open up a file there in
the corner makes a lot of sense and okay
if you know Spanish setup at least not
yet we can keep commentating I'll do the
tour of getting ready to feed the black
dot Squad Bishop oh we got a great
feature chat there if I buy air things
will I be as good as uh the chess player
Fabi how many ELO points do you think
you gain with the good air quality James
well usually everything you always see
this at the stream too as well is we
have a it comes with 100 ELO but the ELO
is sold separately you're gonna have to
you know you gotta ELO not included it's
not included but it's a it's around 100
you can get a hundred but it is sold
separately just so you know at home so
you don't lose your mind and you get mad
when you don't get your 100 ELO so
James they're spitting some facts but
you might not
have by sending us your selfies watching
and enjoying the chess kitka the wackier
the better but keep them coming and we
will reveal the winner at the end of the
show
now I can tell you that all the top
chess players they have them these days
every time I go around to magnus's Flat
he has like no furniture it's just an
air things device in the middle of the
room basically so it seems to work for
them it can't hurt no furniture just to
air things from mice meanwhile a pin you
pin and you try to win if you're
abductor off that's uh black Bishop
exerting pressure on White Center
indirectly pinning one of the white
Knights which uh does protect the key D4
pawn it does feel loose for black Dania
somehow tactically it feels loose for
both sides it feels loose for white in
the sense that his Center is loose but
develop mentally and fundamentally black
is kind of nibbling around the edges
White's got better control of the center
of course things could calm down if
Notre back feels suspicious which you
likely will and Fabio brings his night
out then Notre by castles we enter a
more peaceful stage of the game but it
did feel like maybe white can try to
exploit the uncastled king but I think
White's got bigger fish to fry yep he's
just gone for a nice space advantage in
the middle of the board if you control
the center you often control the game
you can choose to play on the wings a
bit later on you can also step forward
in the center kicking back the Black
Knights kicking back the black pieces I
like what fabby's doing he's uh kind of
evaded this pin there's several
different ways to try and break a pin
but often the best is to Simply protect
the pinned piece and that's what he's
doing with those two knights right now
at the right moment he's going to kick
away the black light squared bishop and
yeah it's uh yet to be seen how nordebec
challenges the white porn Center in
terms of the opening battle first game
clearly fabby's side second game I say
win for Fabi as well in terms of the
opening uh looking like black might have
an uphill struggle later the fact that
he's even thinking and not castling his
King immediately means that he doesn't
necessarily like his position I'll do
satorov
very good point there of course as uh I
mean B5 is weak too as well we do have
an open a file your king is not canceled
my pieces are developed and I have the
flexibility of the options to push D5 or
E5 I can also play H3 at some point kick
the bishop away and grab the bishop pair
that's going to be huge later when this
game opens up I have the Bishops you
won't so of course white is definitely
uh who you would like to play here of
course you got to be careful of the C2
obviously this is the C file with the
tactics that could be uh they could
arise if you're not careful trying to
develop your Queen Bishop could go to D3
attack B5 we get off of the C file there
are things here and definitely want to
be white in this position and I think
you might be right maybe this is on the
cards next for Fabi first surely we'll
see up this tour of Castle there we go
just uh just as we say it and H3 as you
mentioned kicking away this bishop you
don't want to part with the bishop pair
long term these two pieces will wreak
havoc so black has retreated indeed and
maybe now's the time to start going for
this Pawn
what else could white consider here this
Knight's a bit in the way maybe we can
find a better circuit for that in the
near future
just looks really Pleasant so many
options later on you can consider these
Pawn pushers
yeah Dania night before is a
semi-annoying idea of course it can be
met with Bishop B1 but it could be the
response to Bishop D3 of course white
could give away one of his Bishops and
it's really not the end of the world you
could play Bishop D3 Knight B4 and then
for example Queen B3
and recapture with a queen and you have
to understand how this impacts the
position I find these kinds of things
really hard to evaluate choosing a move
in a position like this is hard and
Fabby decides on something very
committal D5
yeah he's been direct you said it
earlier uh in the Daytona direct to
every opportunity just always stepping
forward always going on the front foot
always forcing the opponent to react to
his threats uh what do we think of this
one D5 committal because this bishop
opens up but looks nice to me forcing a
question of this night
I love it I love the style of player and
the the pawn push to D5 locates a square
for one of the pieces on D4 either the
bishop or the Knight but right now that
C2 Bishop is hanging it will fall back
and we see a sequence of moves there
happen rookate a rook trade has been
offered and now a Fabi is having a thing
he's got such a big task ahead of him
because today he has to beat not the
back into matches but it's not only in
division one that we have the storyline
also in division two and three we are
seeing some Grudge matches and some big
finals and we'll get a quick update on
that Simon's joining us in rstudio
Simon's fireworks there as well yeah but
another player who's in the same
situation as Fabiano is um mamajarov
mamajarov has to win against fed
yourself twice to uh get through to
division one the next time and win
division two so we can see his position
at the moment very quick update here uh
he has the white pieces he played quite
an interesting opening he got his kind
of aggressive stuff going and he's got
what I would say is a dominating
position here with the white pieces I
mean he's still got to put the ball in
the back of the net but it's certainly
to my eyes looks like he should be doing
that here against federusev and that
would mean he will take a point lead
over feducev and get a little bit closer
to that result of maybe qualifying and
doing well there what he's got to do in
the position he's just got a queen a
pawn as simple as that really when you
get to the ending when you have an extra
Pawn you've got to get that pawn to the
other end of the board make it a queen
it's also very nice to have the bishop
in this position because the bishop
works all around the ball board it can
work to the left to the right up and
down the Knight is a short range piece
and doesn't have that flexibility it has
to stay in one area of the board to
defend that area so it looks to me like
Mama jar will do well here I mean going
back to obviously division one in a
second I'm just wondering looking at the
games naughty Beck's openings are
looking a bit dodgy today and I'm
wondering if he's trying to save his
openings potentially for the main event
um because I I don't understand why he's
playing these dubious plans really
wow some big updates coming in and Simon
we will be checking in with you several
times today we saw the players playing
on seconds there and here as well action
is on the middle game is heating up as
we were talking before we moved on to
division two that the bishop has arrived
on D4 to challenge that fan shattered
piece on the G7 A1 diagonal white or
black who would you pick here uh to play
Daniel definitely white I think white is
still better the question is to the
extent of White's Advantage I think I
wouldn't say that white is more than
slightly better but more space better
control of the center nice Bishop on D4
of course that was the main idea of
pushing the pawn to D5 to vacate the
square for the bishop and Notre Beck has
to figure out how to keep the fire
burning on the queen side the Knight on
B4 is also loose so more problems it's
definitely harder to play Black from a
practical side
do you agree with that David then once
again uh Fabiano's got the victory out
of the opening the opening victory
definitely I would prefer white here as
well I feel it's easier to play oh nice
move though by up to storef if you can
trade Queens then the fact that he has a
slightly less space in the center will
become less relevant uh but yeah I would
still choose white I think fabi's uh got
this one under control but it could
potentially have been more I'm not sure
I'm a huge fan of what he did in the
sense of pushing forward I think maybe
keeping the flexibility keeping the
options of which Pawn to push in the
middle of the board earlier would have
been a better option but still yet to be
seen whether Abdus toroff can hold off
the pressure here to trade queens or not
I've asked some difficult questions
today that's my next one I'm going to
send it to you James definitely not it's
raining here Queen A4 is actually a good
movie I was really solid after The Rook
trade that was his whole idea of putting
the Rook on A8 after night before that
was very nice of course because the
night looks stranded and if you would
have went Queen B3 at some point then he
would go Queen A4 anyway trying to get
the Queens off the board I have less
space and then that night before B4
looks really good as it can maybe jump
into C2 and maybe try to attack your B
Pawn at some at some point move my
knight so that we can actually trade our
Bishops off make your B2 Pawn a little
weak so very nice idea but he goes
Knight E3 wow 93 just trading Tanya you
might be kind of thinking about bailout
maybe he thinks that he messed up and
it's time to kind of admit that or he
thinks that he's still better in the end
game
Time game is really hard to evaluate
generally the value of a space Advantage
diminishes somewhat when the Queens are
off the board and I think this might be
a case of that if I'm Notre back I'm
seriously considering taking the queen
as you just did and maybe also trade the
dark squared Bishops while you're at it
with 98 because obviously a weaker King
is also much harder to explore and there
are barely any pieces left on the board
yeah I'm just looking at the queen side
both sides B pawns as well wow does the
opposite no don't you dare suggest that
I trade my dark screen Bishop
the idea that I mean avoiding the trade
yes but where's that Bishop going
to already see it that was a strange one
yeah that was definitely uh not on the
radar Bishop H6 definitely wanted to
trade the Bishops I mean look at my
Bishop on D4 and yours on H6 now of
course we Kings Indian fans you know
sometimes we actually do Play Bishop H6
and many lines but this one it's not a
king's idea and this is not the same so
I'm just curious to see what this plan
is he's going to show us
yeah I guess it's difficult for Fabi to
actually move here in a productive way
you can throw a few pieces around you
can push a few different pawns but
what's the plan and that's always the
most difficult question in chess and and
life trust me but uh what's the plan
here for Fabi I'm struggling he might
need a couple of minutes to work it out
yeah and he has eight minutes left two
minutes less than not about Bishop C3 is
attempting move you kind of SWAT the
mosquito but the mosquito comes back
through A6 and it comes back with a
vengeance once that Knight lands on C5
it can jump to A4 it's exerting pressure
on White Center so Fabi is holding off
on Bishop C3 he has to have a clear
follow-up also the b-pawn is now free to
move it can advance to B4 kick the
bishop off the C file all of those
considerations indeed make it difficult
to find a productive move my opinion the
position changed drastically once the
queens were off the board
yeah with the Queens off the board you
would have scope to maybe attack or step
forward in the center and now it's just
a pipe dream I think pushing forward in
the center you'll only kind of Saddle
yourself with weaknesses
I'm looking at this Knight I'm thinking
it's not doing too much but where does
it want to go really unclear I'm looking
at this Knight kind of gets in the way
went to that want to go unclear this
bishop just sitting a bit stuck and a
studio pointed out retreating now
doesn't look too appetizing either wow
okay I like it basic threat but uh it
could be effective James yeah I'll
definitely I'm a fan anytime you see a
g-pawn on a board I'm like is that me
yeah that's that's definitely me all day
G4 is a nice move here of course
obviously it hits a G5 but and it
questions him it makes him do something
which is something you do want to do to
your opponent if you can is ask them
questions what are you going to do with
this move G5 is the threat are you going
to move the bishop yet again I've gained
some space there or are you going to
trade and I've okay he answered it for
us whoa Bishop Perry and the eval Bar
says that is not a move let's see what
is wrong well it's very dubious from a
positional standpoint because you
haven't even given up your Bishop for a
whites Bishop now why does the dark
squares but I think he's going after
that E4 Pawn who I'd be terrified to
play that there might be some 91 move
there like Bishop c194 91 uh yes no but
then black has that fight against very
complicated what if we just move the
bishop I'm not again not sure where how
do you take because I'm pinning you know
oh Rook C1 I'm pinning you and the
Knight on e4 also means that's what it
is yeah hey yeah hey it's like you've
lined up in the in the Archer's
sightseeing what is his idea after the
bishop moves
beats me
yeah it just looks like this Knight is
going to get evicted in the near future
it's going to get kicked out of its nice
little home here and white will be left
with extra space and the bishop pair
which might not sound like much but
could be really important later on maybe
B4 to try to secure the Nike Fabi did
that sort of thing in the last game oh
yeah he didn't meant the night here
yeah still up for grabs but the
evaluation bar and White's favor and
Instinct twice I would be inclined to
agree even if white just takes a time
out at some point and just Retreats
defending this pawn and prevents this
kind of lockdown on the queen side and
it feels like white is the one in
control still big threats of kicking
this Knight out let's see this is on the
board right now Fabi can he milk this
Advantage six and a half minutes
swinging pushing pushing up on him there
everything okay okay this is Fabi 2.0
has Tanya pointed out earlier Fabi 2.0
he's just going at him every game in the
heat putting on the heat here guys
hopefully you can handle the heat in the
kitchen E5 Pawn takes Knight takes
right even with Queens off the board
somehow the black king doesn't feel
entirely safe somehow it feels like
you're yeah taking over the momentum
over the initiative here
love it I love it from Fabi very strong
very strong very aggressive player there
by Fabiano caruana from the start of the
day wins the opening battle and doesn't
stop after the Queens have been traded
off we saw him go with the Deep on we
saw him go with the Jeep on and now we
see him go with the e-pawn big questions
too not a back does he trade does he go
back with the Knight not even does look
extremely tense on the camera we see him
reaching out he is about to make a move
there is so much difference in their
body language Fabi just looks a lot more
composed right now
cursed rest day
because it cause everything yeah
bro if he's going to complain the rules
you know why did you give me time off to
kill I wanted to play but uh yeah I will
say though that when the clock stick
down in the previous game and also when
they played each other a few days ago it
was Abdul sotorov who seemed the more
composed when both sides had about 30
seconds left that's how he managed to
squeeze past carowana a few days ago and
in the first game there when Fabi was
winning only had 30 seconds left he did
Panic so he looks calm now Fabby but uh
trust me sometimes a cold exterior does
musk kind of nervous Waters inside
so right now it looks good on the board
though for Fabi gotta say yeah
definitely so if 98 is there some tricks
it's probably something is wrong I guess
smells wrong 98 just
feels wrong there yeah I thought about
that E6 doesn't work though well black
doesn't have to take the pawn like
Bishop A4 there okay yeah you're right
let's show that it's a really it's a
cool it's a cool tactic yeah and then
take on Bishop takes E6 take take and
Knight D4
yeah lovely lovely most common type of
tactic and chest the double attack
really nice geometry here The Rook
cannot find a safe Square to protect its
Bishop the Knight dominates everything
uh really nice trick but Daniel you
mentioned here that maybe black doesn't
have to take necessarily on this Square
maybe you take once and then run away
with the bishop somewhere oh yeah it's
kind of annoying still should be better
for white E7 is a weak you can
so try to deliver Checkmate on the f8
Square but you'll have to cross you know
the Rubicon to do that so maybe you take
on C2 and play Rook D4 but lots of
options everywhere yeah you somehow
sneak in and
Checkmate that King zigzag but yeah this
is the type of thing that is going
through his mind right now Abdus he's
wondering whether he can allow that type
of Pawn structure white stepping forward
even further if he takes I don't know
somehow wow the bar reacts is it losing
immediately somehow but uh just this one
feels all wrong the Knight is so strong
here then I can maybe later jump into
this Outpost anchored by its Pawn even
if white just opens things up even
further it will favor the Bishops the
opening of the position
yeah I do think as well the black king
look at it it's just caged by the white
Bishop he could be playing down a piece
later in the end game it feels like
everything is in White's favor tactics
and the strategy here I'm getting some
Deja Vu yeah
do you think there'll be another miracle
escaping yeah that's the question no
Rebecca's cooking it up right now I
think he has to go 98 but he's just
taking the pawn and even here D6 should
not be ruled out but Fabby does
Recapture on A5 he's likely to play D6
here
but you still need that final nail in
the coffin where is it going to come
from is it going to be an attack against
the king is he going to pick off one of
Black's vulnerable pieces Knight C6 has
to be considered here as well
96 is pretty nasty his Knight takes D5
though I don't know what to make of that
oh ridiculous no then Bishop takes C2
and Bishop takes C6 that's beautiful
put it on the board we've got to put it
on the board Knight C6 directing Knight
takes porn if you take this one disaster
this Knight is pretty much trapped and
uh or just to show Pawn to C7 you're
going to deliver a Checkmate here Rook
takes Pawn it's gonna end in a back
ranker and uh yeah instead Daniel what a
move Knight takes D5
yeah what's happening here and I thought
Bishop takes C2 because if black takes
you could take the Knight but black
suddenly returns and takes the Knight
and defends his own Knight that's so
ridiculous Bishop B4 and then there's E6
the pawn steps in to guard the Knight
that's exactly what's gonna happen
literally clearly clearly Knight C6 is a
very tempting move though Fabi misses
Knight takes D5 he is likely to play it
yeah I think you win unless black has
that move unless black has that trick so
I've do satorov he did spend a couple of
minutes before this he realized that
Knight C6 doesn't work White's most
natural move Fabi needs something
different we do have an active Rook
after D6 takes takes Rook takes we are
hitting F6 you move the Knight I play
Rook maybe A6 or something like that and
I have an active Rook with some chances
to maybe get the Rook to the seventh
rank Rook A6 to A7 the knight's still on
pre like if you mess up moving the
bishop somewhere Bishop C2 or K8 there
right so I mean maybe D6 is is uh is the
move we go for Wow and we Bishop takes
C2 that is a hard move to make yeah yeah
we see the engine suggestions there and
Bishop takes night that's tough it feels
like you that's on tap for later you can
play that move a bit later on incredibly
hard Dania just uh from a psychological
I don't even understand the idea let me
confess enter Bishop C2 Bishop C2 I
thought maybe Rook C1 pinning the bishop
but black can always play B3
so maybe it's the place what about
Bishop C2 Knight C6
oh
James Bishop C2 business oh my God
Bishop D1 and then 97 and you take but I
think five in the end oh my goodness but
it's a beautiful idea oh it doesn't work
it is something like that probably yeah
it leads to a draw it looks like but uh
what could the idea be Bishop takes
Knight apparently this is the only movie
four maybe yeah only move to give a
significant Advantage maybe Rook D4 down
here hitting this Pawn if black steps it
forward now Knight C6 is James that's
crazy at last this is finally a little
the Nuance like he finds this man look
you need to get him checked okay check
him yeah did they have fair play over
there Fabi crib we got to figure that
out right now if he does that if he
plays Fisher takes Knight he's a genius
I mean we know he is but it confirms it
one more time Bishop takes Knight the
key move in this position
this is such a big moment for Fabiano
one more time he is in driver's seat in
this match but it all comes down to
whether he will find the only way to
keep that advantage on the other hand
the first move that you were looking at
the Knight jumped to that C6 Square
immediately such a human approach such a
natural move to make and that would just
give not a bag the Tactical chance to
neutralize all the advantage Fabi taking
a long thing three and a half minutes
he's left for three and a half minutes
on the clock and he's burnt three and a
half minutes D6 not the best move but
still keeps a chunk of the advantage
he's gone around the world and ends up
playing the most natural move
it is very tempting we've talked about
it but after black takes and jumps
forward maybe with the Knight to E4
black is hanging by a thread but is
there a knockout blow
yeah it looks like there will be
resources to defend that one for black
but yeah we can't blame Fabi the move we
showed extremely difficult you don't
really want to part with the bishop pair
top players they do tend to have this
mental block Bishops overnight every
time so actually Bishop takes Knight
there yeah wasn't uh an easy one and
he's gone direct it's very natural as
Daniel says and still some tricks
talking of Tricks whoa Knight A3 jeez
Big Fellas next Friday man oh my
goodness that's a move for you right
there I don't think you can now watch
five we play Bishop A2 or something
insane
out of here oh my goodness this is gross
guys we gotta slow down at this moment
David what is this move it just
sacrifices a whole piece yeah he is
however hitting this Rook now on D1
there's a discovered attack if we go
back action replay this diagonal was
blocked he's moved the Knight out the
way with gain of time he's hitting this
record Daniel mentioned a crazy move in
this position it is the best engine
suggestion
get out of here I was gonna say earlier
that we might get to see this move if
Fabby plays D6 I didn't think it would
be here and Bishop A2 can be met with B3
and then maybe
what's happening here this Pawn is
attacked this bishop is attacked this
Knight is attacked just pure chaos and
only two minutes to navigate all of this
what's the most natural move here you
cannot take this Knight because your
Rook will drop at the bottom of the
board
can you move this Rook it feels like you
don't really want to you're protecting
this bishop you're protecting this Pawn
process of elimination actually the two
and the second and third best moves here
maybe a bit more a bit even more
difficult
wow wow Knight C6 never gonna happen
your mind the idea of this one I mean
I'm not gonna even explain the idea I
guess is to push forward and try to make
a new queen and the queen will Checkmate
the king but this is never ever gonna
happen that would be the move of the
year if Fabby drops his Knight into C6
right now I think he's a move of the
century over the century wow far more
natural but now black does have the
opportunity perhaps this bishop but then
Pawn takes E7 or Rook takes B4 what a
tactical game no Queens on the board
this is crazy but then Bishop E8 Rook d8
but it just loses what happens I will
get to play G5 about 10 years later than
we thought he would
white wall breakthrough on the back rank
here this is what fabi's banking on he
wants to break through to that black
king we can't fault him for this he's
giving up a piece he's going for
checkmate even in the end game it's up
to nodded back now to defend not easy
so let's see what this time to as well
anything can happen literally anything
can and will happen
three but not a back that was insane
that was insane definitely trying to
figure out this position reminds me of
standing in the Paris Metro and trying
to figure out where each of the trains
go like what is happening here and it
just keeps getting crazier with every
move there's less Clarity not more
but we see the eval bar it stays even
usual chat story crazy wild action on
the board but the Silicon friend doesn't
budge at all there is a big threat on
the board with Rook d8 coming in why is
this position still Level it's obviously
equals honey can't you see obviously
maybe it's rookie a here because like
what is the move Bishop is obviously
okay something to eat something doesn't
know what world is on
yeah this is more complicated than
trying to learn Norwegian no this is
just another level of uh I mean this is
a new language this position in front of
us so right now the material count is
White having two pawns for a piece but
blacks pieces are scattered around the
board that Black Knight on B1 on White's
first rank trapped not really coming
back anytime soon Max Bishop hit
blocking squares as well Abby's playing
for long-term compensation here that's
sick I was like what happens on just
Bishop D1 but maybe Rook D4 go back to
d8 is probably the idea so if I can go
Bishop D1 C2 within Rook D4 anyway maybe
please how do you stop Rook d8 again
exactly I haven't gotten the memo on
that yet
maybe black is gonna attack White's Pawn
White's very strong E7 Pawn oh Rook C7
what a heartless moved but you go after
the source of the problems oh my
goodness and then maybe Knight C6 that's
so annoying wow
I like wins oh my goodness calculation
of everything this is the craziest
position I think we've seen on the tour
this season it's just so uh just hard to
understand first of all there we go not
for another event not for another back
96 tempting but I think it loses so that
is an easy way again nice Rook T8 and F6
58 and F6 takes oh King F7 wow Works C
you know you can't go anything oh my
goodness you just immediately lose crazy
I'm gonna Jinx him what have you played
in a minute right what do you even play
you can lose this you are down a piece
last time I checked
but then black plays F6 again oh my
goodness getting out of hands under a
minute for Fabi and usually I mean we've
seen this time and time even in the last
tour and the last you know match up
every time Fabi gets in trouble or time
trouble he gets in trouble I mean it's
just he just doesn't make the best moves
which happens naturally Rick d8 on the
board F6 Andy balbar approves 47 seconds
of Fabi three minutes for Naughty back
picks up the E7
plus the machine he
'll win now there's a big thread on the
board Knight F6 coming up did you see
notibex body language there he was
shocked by that one I don't know whether
he missed it or whether he thought it
just wasn't working this is a night
check but black has created some room he
didn't even wait for his case
and no dirt bikes Knight is on fabby's
night's initial Square that's never a
good sign it's like the white pieces
have invaded the black have the black
piece of invaded where's the game like
that you know where the pawns start
on the white spawn started on the
seventh and black spawn start in the
second it's like that wow if you had to
predict a result of this game at this
moment what would it be draw
they're both playing equally well that's
the problem they're both playing like
Geniuses normally we see chess games one
side place like a genius the other side
makes a few mistakes and it's a logical
result this one G5 doesn't look half bad
wow will we see that Daniel just pushing
a pawn forward trying to get the black
king towards those two white Intruders
on the edge of the board there's two
white pieces
I don't see any moves at this point my
mind is frazzled how are the players
staying focused after such a complicated
game
wow oh no boy I couldn't find a way for
a way to meet this move Bishop takes G5
there's a check on E1 and then the king
steps over you can also play after X G4
and this is the first time in my life
I'm saying this is the bishop on the
black Bishop on C2 attacks the White
Knight on H7
wow just long board Vision here full
board awareness and under 30. wow white
only has one move to stay in the game F4
according to the computer
and that's an inaccuracy
yeah black is going to give a check just
to get this Rook out of Dodge there we
go on on G4 and take E6 oh yeah yeah
there's also King G6 now black has to
make a very tough choice and that
apparently of course is not the move wow
I should have learned by now the obvious
move is never correct obvious I kind of
want to push this pawn and hit the
Knight and then I want to come back and
Checkmate you somehow but I don't know
if this works either this is just
complete chaos
F4 is an excellent move
these guys too good that's crazy D7
check now where does the king go back to
G8 and white is going to get mated in
the event of Knight F6
checks Unstoppable mate to the white
king you can hit the button you can hit
the button 20 seconds it's probably
about to go down
he loses the second minor piece is this
all over
two nights down the one hope for Fabi is
somehow trading off the Rooks and the
harder Factor trading off the Bishops is
two nights on their own cannot deliver
checkmate
but black has so many pieces such a full
Army here two nights they're going to
surely do the business here for black
this reminds me of that game where
notorbeck had the pawns and Fabi had the
extra pieces it all
comes back to a Full Circle here but can
Notre bag get that night out of B1 yeah
Fabi needs to at least somehow get his
pawns rolling as well create some type
of counter play nine seconds for Fabi
again it's the clock that's come back to
haunt him we said it earlier he looks so
calm until he got down under a minute
and when nordebec's throwing these spicy
moves on the board how can you keep up I
don't think anyone can so so tough and
the Knight is out there's the answer
so masterful that's crazy this is gonna
be it's hard I mean psych blow in the
first round for Fabi right psych blow in
the second round for foppy I mean this
is hard this is very hard for Fabi to
come back from this especially if he
loses this game yeah in both games he
was the one who was in driver's seat
right out of the opening the one who was
pushing for the win and here we see
nodded back with two extra pieces but
there is some technique to be shown Fabi
going ahead with those pawns it's still
not over absolutely not eight seconds so
far be one minute on the clock for not a
bag it's so crucial that not abec has
those extra seconds right now
yep those extra seconds could be
decisive and still a complicated end
game and uh big question now for another
Beck his Knight is attacked the white
Rook is eyeing up the black Bishop
you've got to be a bit careful here you
either have to give a check to the white
king or you have to drop back with the
Black Knight he drops in another check I
wasn't even looking at this side of the
board so much is happening and oh King
F3 there's Rook takes E3 and Bishop of
course a Fabi sidesteps it and I don't
know what that was all about from Notre
back maybe he thought he missed
something yeah maybe it's just so many
things you're looking at him you look at
you like bro sheesh there's just so much
going on right that's real this is
exactly right Knight takes C3 minor
pieces
on the clock
s
surely going to round up the remaining
white pawns they're not that far
Advanced they're all a bit weak but
still some trances families now whoa
he's driving through the war zone Rook
H2 and the bishop starts by blockading
the pawn here comes the other one both
flanks just throw them forward fabi's
Musa at least easy now he just has to
throw pawns forward and cross his
fingers and pray but Black's Rook is
going to start a clean up operation now
move up for assistance King D6 and King
C6 comes to mind
First full blockade from the black
Bishop
another Port advances
Four Points we should mention as well if
the Rooks disappear black is winning as
long as he can get rid of all of White's
pawns bishop and Knight together can
deliver Checkmate the top players know
how to do that not the rest of us but uh
but uh yeah this one should be a matter
of time now he's going after the pawns
wait it's just too slow
hands only move one square at a time
sadly geez man give a bunch of Chucks
but it's not gonna be helpful not even a
bunch just one check on the board
another G Pawn will fall but there is a
pin along the edge file not super easy
to get out of it
[Music]
he's backing himself to win this end
game with two pieces but the pawns they
remain G6
I think I would have just taken the
Rooks off there and just made another
Beck prove it
the pawns are dropping now though the
bishop is coming with some checks six
seconds
no moves
I'm leaving space for the bishop
unbelievable
sealed fabi's face he's getting ready to
resign and there we go we have a result
what a game it's been Insanity I'm
walking away I'm punching the air wow
another disappointing game for Fabiano
if I want another back takes the win
with the black pieces when he got the
advantage surgical Precision there by
the 18 year old
Olympic gold medalist 2021 World rapid
Champion look at that determination look
at that Focus just incredible resilience
so far in the match by the Uzbek Phenom
it's going to be tough for a Fabi to
fight back against that Talent that's
scary that is scary level of talent he's
18 years old you can say that again
imagine what he'll be like in five years
that was honestly
art that was some sort of Modern Art
that I don't understand but clearly the
players understood it and Fabi they know
what you know what they say the player
who loses is the one who makes the next
to last mistake Fabby sadly made the
last mistake incredible win by Notre
back he's one game away oh my gosh if he
wins the next game he does win the chess
get got but Savvy he's had winning
positions in both games David he could
have taken this one as well Fabby could
have taken it but in the end he couldn't
cope with the resilience the Artistry
and the ruthlessness of nordeback Abdus
this is the moment that after impressed
me the most it looks completely crazy
it's chaotic Black's Knight has somehow
ended up on the B1 Square whites Knight
and Bishop have somehow ended up on H6
and H uh H7 here and it was this move G5
out of the blue out of nowhere just
opening up indirectly a threat against
the White Knight this was so impressive
because if the Knight steps back the
black king can simply win a piece the
bishop is trapped the Knight is gonna
fall as well instead Bishop takes born
happened a rook check and another
incredibly impressive move pushing the
pawn forward hitting this white knight
and to show the idea we need to go one
or two moves deeper if the white knight
now had saved itself dropped back we
would have seen a checkmating attack the
black Bishop drops back the white king
is caught in a cage to spot all of this
with no time in your clock so impressive
he is a genius
some genius moves there by the 18 year
old not a bag Abdu sakrov after that
shaky start in game one game two when he
got that opportunity he just never let
go of it and now it is on Fabiano
caruana he has to not only win one game
to level the match but he needs to
eventually win the match to go into the
Grand Final reset only two more rapid
games remain which means for the match
to go on Fabi has to win two games back
to back or at least take it to the
Armageddon it is a fire on the board and
we will be back with more just kid aft
action after the stretch break four are
non-subscribers those of you who are
subscribed stay right here we've got
something special coming up
[Music]
do such rob it takes the lead in his
match against Fabiano caruana but you
can never write off the world and number
seven take a peek into the genius mind
of the 2018 World Championship
Challenger
you ready all right mating five why to
move
foreign
if you go 97 I go King h8
which page five yeah that's
that's not working out
okay Queen G6 has to be the right first
move yes
that's right yes very good next one
this is going to be a study maybe you
know it maybe you don't
why to move
looks kind of familiar
but
okay yeah Rook D2 rugby two review
so how do you start Queen A3 rookie two
Rook D2 d206 A3 it would be two okay two
will be on very nice very nice
foreign
super impressive stuff there especially
that last study we at the studio were
also trying to solve along with Fabi uh
Daniel I saw you enjoyed that that was
some creativity there I love studies
it's so funny because I told David when
it was projected I said something like
oh this looks Vaguely Familiar and then
Fabby said the exact same thing
beautiful patterns there obviously Fabby
Notre back we're watching Geniuses at
play I bow before them
and Fabiano caruana is an absolute beast
when it comes to calculation for all the
chess kids out there David is solving
studies a good way to improve
calculation yeah solving studies puzzles
uh any chess content basically is
helpful and uh playing games as well
just getting in that mindset a bit of
focus that kind of gets the juices
flowing yeah it can help your vision it
helps your understanding it helps
everything yeah
and for Fabi right now the big question
is what can help him in the next game
that's coming up because he needs to win
to level the match he is playing against
a very on Farm not a back of the satrobe
he's just 18 years old but he's been
super impressive and uh David here
breaks down one of nottyback's best
games of all times take a look
foreign
[Music]
the teenage Prodigy from Uzbekistan had
his first big breakthrough in 2021 when
he won the world rapid championship
since then he has smashed through the
2700 barrier and even LED his country to
their first ever gold medals at an
Olympiad it is abdisotarov's end game
skills that truly set him apart from his
peers he has a very mature approach to
the end game as evidenced by this win
against Magnus Carlson in the 2021 World
rapid championship
in this position abdusitorov had white
he is ahead in this race white porn only
being one square away from promotion and
after a careless move by Magnus playing
the pawn to B4 he didn't get tempted he
wasn't greedy he did not capture this
Pawn instead delivering a very accurate
check this immediately provoked a
mistake from Carlson the end game is
winning for white anyway but Carlson
Advanced his King to the corner and this
cross-check forcing the queen exchange
won the game for Abdul satorov after the
Queens disappeared white is about to
make a new Queen and he went on to win
the game
to win the game and he went on to win
the 2021 World rapid Championship making
him the youngest ever World a rapid
Champion David if there was one quality
that you think is key in abdullah's play
what is it oh one quality he has
hundreds Tanya that set him apart uh I
would just say his fighting Spirit we've
seen it against Fabi so far today two
difficult positions somehow he emerges
with the lead he just never goes down
without a fight he's always on the front
foot always putting his opponent under
pressure and it's paying off with his
results
it has been a fantastic match so far not
a bad leads we are having so much fun
with the chest but that's not the only
fun that we've been having while David
has been breaking down the action for us
David also took a little
quiz at a school earlier we will be
revealing the full video later but take
a look at this because it was a lot of
fun for everyone except David
what's the capital of Guyana
and you know this answer yeah oh my gosh
I thought we'd start easy like what's
two times two what year did Queen
Boudicca die I think another Century
what are the effects of the black death
and where did it originate from what do
all the coordinating conjunctions put in
a certain order spell out I want you to
clearly explain how you find out the
percentage of a certain number clearly
explain
[Music]
David chess is a lot easier yeah those
kids they might have faces of angels but
they are mean
we will be revealing the whole video and
showing you guys the fun that the kids
had with David in that quiz earlier this
week right now the big questions that we
have got is what's going on in the other
two divisions as well so let's check in
with Simon big game feather CF taking on
shark Simon what do you have for us
yeah so um in that game Shaq mamajarov
has taken a lead uh he played some great
moves there and this is the current
position that we can see he has the
black pieces it looks fairly even but
let's remember mamajarov has to win two
matches there to go through and uh you
know that last game you're looking at I
mean I'm just still I'm just blown away
by Naughty Beck's playing we're talking
about best moves and uh well in this
game they're playing some great moves
but I have to say I think the best moves
that I've seen so far is probably James
Canty's dancing on the desk so are we
gonna get more of that James a bit more
dancing a bit more of your best moves
honestly I'm saying look at that I don't
know if that's just magical magical
and it's great we can get that so yeah
so this batch so far Mama jarov looks in
a good position to be fighting back and
uh trying to take it to another match
and in the third division very quickly
um Alan Petro is leading against Harry
Krishna there so he's also in a great
situation in that match as well
in division two that ten thousand
dollars for the winner and uh the ticket
to the division one of the next
championship
on a way to make a comeback while it
looks like he might get to the Grand
Final reset it's not so clear of a Fabi
it is not about Abdu satra of who leads
the match and we will be starting game
three not a back starts with the white
pieces it wasn't game one that Fabi had
that big moment the big chance to take
the lead are we expecting him to stick
to the same opening because it worked so
well no more Bishop G5 and Bishop D2
from notorbeck though please maybe one
C4 he played that move with a lot of
success in the world Blitz championship
in the world rapid which he won so we'll
see
yeah it depends on his mood as well uh
often after a win you want to kind of
continue the momentum you want to
continue putting your opponent Under
Pressure especially knowing now that
Fabiano will be a bit fragile but it
also makes sense to play solid because
then he guarantees that he goes into the
fourth game only needing a draw of
desotorov uh it depends much on his mood
his opening choice I think yeah and the
ball is in family score to try to create
some Chaos on the board but that's
exactly what we've been getting in the
first two games it does start with the
Queen spawn opening and another similar
position to what we had in game one
Bishop G5 will we have it it's aragos in
yeah I was going to say maybe another
line like Queen A4 and A3 which is
really fashionable black can equalize
but it's a very tricky line I've faced
it a lot online let's see if Fabby
remembers his prep
yeah it often involves a pawn sacrifice
certain variations but okay black has
castled his King nice and safe white
needs to continue development today he
remembers
to me Daniel yeah you've got such an
adorable photo coming in of kids just
kids around the world following the
chess kid cup keep them coming because
you could win and air things device how
cool is it that they've got this big
screen the television with the broadcast
on I want that set up
I love the fact that they're just
completely ignoring us and they're
playing their own game but they're
future champions for sure with that
level of concentration David they're
inspired yeah some uh yeah great chess
kids out there already keep them coming
we want to see more using our voices to
fuel their brilliant moves very good
kids
meanwhile on the board uh one of the
chess kids one of the best chess kids in
the world Abdus tour of is he a kid
still nine eight nine eighteen nineteen
eighteen and uh great position for him
Black's Pawn structure what do we make
of this on the board it's pretty gross I
mean just put it out there it's
definitely disgusting but at the same
time of course there are some some
assets to it you can use the G file at
some point especially if the king
White's King goes kingside we can
actually move our King go root G8 in
many cases called Knight G6 and
sometimes Knight H4 or F4 using the F
Pawn
um as we play F5 you know maybe we play
F4 as well there's lots of things that
we can do in this position but I am not
too familiar with this Theory I'm just
understanding what the structure looks
like Danielle are you familiar with this
Theory here after that all okay I don't
think Notre back is either okay Black's
position looks pretty ugly but I guess
the king side is functional you've got
some squares under control the Knight on
F3 is restricted by The Pawn on F6 and
Fabi continues to Blitz out his moves
Queen could come out to A5 and black
could start encircling those weak Queen
side Pawns
yeah black is very active so often when
you do have these long-term structural
kind of deficiencies you need to
compensate by short-term Dynamic active
play and okay he's taking a pawn there
and he's saying to I'll do store of
either you're going to be a pawn down or
if you move your bishop and go and
recapture this Pawn you might lose even
more time and you still haven't castled
remember indirectly hitting the bishop
again with the black Rook some questions
to answer I really like what fabby's
doing in the opening I've got to say
and I really like how quickly he's
playing the first two games we did see
the clock eventually played such a big
role even though Fabi having good
positions some inaccuracies happen and
now the back was on top of the game so
really important for Fabi to keep the
clock under control from the very start
is that an approach that he's
consciously taken for this game yeah you
know what I think uh her father actually
has had a great approach every game I
mean it's just really you're playing
norterbeck right now and it's you have
to beat him twice first two games he got
great openings great positions couldn't
convert psychologically that's
definitely difficult and you're one game
away from defeat right so you have to
like win two in a row here it's really
hard it's definitely an uphill battle
for father here so you just have to
focus on the game in front of you but of
course he has goodness good positions
and hopefully he can convert is what
he's working on he's gonna come down
come down really good on the clock but
what about the position the opening
battle Rook C8 we see another back is
the one to slow down first David you're
mentioning these threats with capturing
the Central Pawn x-raying that Bishop on
C4 is not a back feeling the heat just a
little bit he might well be often
especially if you keep struggling out of
the opening you start to see ghosts and
you start to fear your opponent's
preparation a bit and I know here I
would be panicking slightly with white
this bishop indirectly attacked for
example if we Castle black will take
this Pawn hitting the bishop and the
only way now to keep it defended while
regaining the pawn would be to take with
the queen but yeah good reaction there
correct reaction there I think Daniel
because the queen now defending the
bishop but you're left with ruins on the
queen side these pawns will drop off a
bit later on and therefore I'm expecting
a bishop Retreat this bishop needs to
move I think he's choosing between one
of these two squares the other direction
you could maybe retreat in as well but
either way Daniel you mentioned the
black queen coming out as well hitting
the white Pawn hitting the king behind
it and still questions to answer if
white steps forward to block then there
might be a night jump again continuing
the momentum hitting this Pawn that
might be the black Bishop coming out to
the square to this Square yeah just
feels like black has all the Activity
one bad thing about Black's uh position
here is this Pawn structure of course
but right now not relevant actually just
like Bishop B3 and castling I mean
Bishop D3 Queen X5 okay whatever you can
have the little Pawn right now just get
out of the way Castle I'm gone there
yeah eval Bar says Black's a little
better obviously but in Ponte C5 maybe
there is some problems
um with D7 at some point Knight H4 just
feels like if I open this game up maybe
if I can even get Rook C1 to C4 and Rook
lift it's gonna be difficult to do that
without like a queen takes C1 obviously
so we need to be careful but there is
some play on whites on Black's King side
in fact if we can get obviously the
right configuration Knight H4 Queen H5
is what we're trying to do if we could
Rook lift I mean black has some problems
there the structure is definitely a
problem before black here but let's see
how he handles it Rook to C8 and it's on
uh norterbeck's move yeah Queen A5
coming uh many active moves for black at
least Black's next few moves are
automatic for white it's much harder to
kind of uh realize exactly how you
should be setting up how you should be
defending and covering everything so I
think he's paused at the right moment
Abdus tour of
and he does go into a three and a half
minute think uh it's all about finding
those critical moments and these top
Grand Masters they do that so well they
know exactly when it's time to take a
pause to go into a thing and that's
exactly what we're seeing by not a Beck
right now he hasn't castled playing with
the black pieces given the math
situation is this a dream start for Fabi
it is and it has been for all three
games but he hasn't reaped the rewards
maybe the third time is the charm Notre
back has chosen a move that was censured
by the eval bar Bishop drops back to A2
staying on the diagonal maybe thinking
about a D5 Pawn break later Fabby
proceeding according to plan maybe Notre
back also wants to capture on C5 as
James pointed out in response to Queen
takes C3 but I'm feeling a little bit
skeptical I wonder what his idea
actually is yeah and I must admit I'm
really surprised Fabi moved instantly
I'm not sure maybe he's still in his
opening preparation but the reason I was
so skeptical of white retreating uh in
this Direction with his Bishop just a
couple of moves ago I thought maybe
black would take in the center and then
just plant his Bishop on B5 saying you
cannot Castle through chess this was
nasty yeah I was a bullet dodged by
another back yes seriously wow suddenly
this white king maybe it's safe for the
next few moves but long term if you
cannot Castle through the island of that
Bishop you will be suffering but uh Fabi
insisted on attacking the spawn
instantly White Castles and now he's
hesitating to take on not to take
looks like free food looks like uh yeah
it's up for grabs I can't resist free
food you know just take that pawn why
not I guess we just take take in oh so
what happens after we take on C5 and
open up the game D7 is hanging
temporarily yeah there's Bishop B5 all
right there should be five and then
maybe the problem is rookie one there's
this very unpleasant
now Rook fd8 there's Knight D4 so it's
still a little complicated but black
could capture on C5 at any moment
Yep this Pawn also dropping black will
emerge report up but Fabby maybe he's
worried about uh yeah I'm not sure
exactly what but maybe he's just worried
about his King I do see the evaluation
bar slide up a lot so that's his mistake
I'm just trying to figure out why yeah
Knight D2 wow the queen g494 ideas
have you just got Bishop C6 there though
but then I get the queen in there I mean
this is it's just annoying like you feel
that white definitely has some attacking
chances obviously this could be very
strong I think you might be right James
just to show for example Pawn takes porn
would be a disaster for black
catastrophe you hit the queen when the
queen moves anywhere you take this pawn
and white would win material so I think
uh yeah he just was too afraid of that
variation and maybe rightly so he Parks
his Bishop on C6 at least now he covers
some key squares along this diagonal so
still very much in the balance now
and now that the E for square is control
so Fabi could be very much threatening
to pick up those pawns on the queen side
and not a back with his classic typical
chess kit pose that we have been seeing
uh trying to figure out a way and he
does go with James idea does bring the
Knight back a nice retreating move to
open up the way for the queen you come
back to go forward next Queen G4 Knight
C4 coming up things could start getting
tricky for black on the king side all
thanks to that pawn structure and Fabi
instantly takes on D4 and I think a big
part of the appeal is that the queen now
can shuttle itself around the fifth rank
so he can meet a check on G4 with Queen
G5 you could play it immediately and
threaten Checkmate in one another break
something tells me he's gonna see that
but he's got to decide how he does it F3
isn't an option because you drop the E3
pawn and you cut the path for White's
Queen to the king side but you can play
G3 you can play E4 you could even put a
knight on F3 it's a tough decision he
doesn't have all that much time
yeah big decision just to point out
Daniel yeah important to F3 does drop
this little guy as you mentioned and
yeah this one I'm reluctant somehow it
does feel like you might later get uh
kebabed I don't know why that word
popped into my head maybe it's not free
food I was talking about earlier you
might get to court along this diagonal
like it's going to be sure
oh man we've had a lot of Kebab here too
yeah that's why it's so funny it just
pops into my head after you know like 7
30 p.m that's right that's exactly right
that's funny but E4 comes with downsides
as well now the negative is that after
black centralizes The Rook what could be
more natural this one is weak suddenly
White's pawns we talk about obtaining
the center in chess but a lot of pieces
have been traded off these are
vulnerable rather than a strength
necessarily right now after that Rook
tape move I actually like Queen E1 this
definitely appeals to me these very you
know like these attacking type positions
because after obviously Rook takes D4 we
have Knight of three my idea here is to
play F4 and root Cliff so I want to just
get the queen out of out of Dodge
immediately and be able to play F4 and
Rook F3 and then try to keep attacking
you
this thing moves right now and I think
Fabi will go for this we might well see
something like you said James on the
board oh and Bishop B5 there traps The
Rook but white has F4 to clear up some
space so do you even Rook lift bro
nice yeah this position has all the
potential as well of uh kind of a repeat
of what we've seen I need a break after
that last game that was
be still my Beating Heart we have been
seeing some white chess uh by these two
players in game one and game two and
currently not a bag does lead the match
and this one promises to be another
exciting game uh you can tell with just
the asymmetry that exists in the
position not about going for space in
the center but the drawback of that is
that you do end up weakening those bonds
as well and we've been often talking
about trades in positions if you're if
you can get the Queens off the board if
you can't get the Rooks off the board
given the pawn formation that's there
it's an unusual one not a standard one
who would trades benefit here
long term I would say black just because
uh the black king does have the
potential of being a bit weak with
Queens off the board you'll never get
checkmated also long term let's switch
our Focus away from the King side to the
other flank black does have the two
versus one majority on the queen side
you could imagine if all the pieces are
off the board those pointers would just
simply run through to Victory so I think
Queen trade uh would very much suit
Fabby right now how about you guys
I'm definitely the same I mean hey you
know your P your structure is not the
greatest so you do probably want to
trade the light Square Bishop I think is
a little bit better on C6 than the a21
it was kind of biting on granites what
they say in the chess books right so
it's not really hitting anything
um there as well I also have the file
first to the file a lot of times you can
have a little bit more activity so I do
have the C file if I may be able to move
my Bishop Bishop B5 I mean yeah
definitely trades will help black here
because white definitely has some type
of serious attack if we're able to get
Queenie one imagine just Queen E1 F4
Rook F3 and we are actually it's almost
Grand Prix like after Rick F3 Rook G3 or
H3 swing the queen over maybe even a
bishop B1 and like just put every piece
that I have at the king over there it
can be very bad for for black James I
have to say queen E1 to me is such a
difficult move to spot because you kind
of trap your own Rook to F1 you have to
spot the idea of f4 and that's of course
your style of play you want to go F4 you
want a rook lift you want to give
Checkmate but how does one how do all
the chess kids watching out there how do
they come to this move and by the way we
might be seeing it happen because it is
on the board Rook D4 is a threat right
now absolutely Rick D4 Rick d8 is on the
board now of course A lot of times is uh
how you find these moves is look at
creative players on the D5 creative move
there that's a very creative move but
find players that are very aggressive
and creative and watch their Games tower
Richard report right by dear Joe Bava
you have a adibon right all these
players that are very creative and
strong Daniel never did the prophet
himself right of course you know the
creative players here and if you want to
play in games and fall asleep and be
boring we have David over here okay we
have David for that for that slow chest
that you you know you want to fall
asleep on but it works every time of
course so we do you got to watch the
games that you like
oh we're watching this game right now
and it is heating up D5 on the board
that's not a move that you're expecting
because to my eyes it looks like that
pawn can be picked up David you've got
to explain this one to us I think we're
getting the explanation now from Abdul
satoroff I'm still skeptical I must
admit maybe I'm influenced by the eval
bar here still skeptical
maybe the queen should have dropped back
to G7 but maybe Fabi was afraid of a do
even lift bro on F3 yeah that black
Queen's running out of squares you've
got to say she's almost trapped it
reminds me of fabi's Queen yesterday
against Jordan van Ferris who got
trapped on this Square on H4 by a
lifting Rook so could we see lightning
strike twice and Tanya you asked why why
is sacrificed important I guess it's
just bought him a bit of time with which
to start attacking the black queen and
also black structure is even worse than
it was so even if white ends up a pawn
down back does have those two weak F
pawns uh that maybe you can hit a bit
later
I don't know I need to uh kind of refer
here to the more attacking players Among
Us James what do you think about well
okay so we'll be looking at E5 I mean E5
is my top move Knight F3 I think black
can get away with Queen takes F4 I don't
see a clear follow-up there because once
the Center opens up the risk of a queen
trade becomes a lot higher so white
wants to try to avoid that for as long
as possible if white plays E5 black can
also push D4 to try to cover the F3
Square then why I could push E6 and
we're off again you know wow suddenly
yeah Bishop 55 an absolute chaos one
Rook F3 you know wow we could uh
definitely get caught in some rabbit
holes here some crazy variations other
than E5
being too much because you don't really
want to allow black to take and start
opening up the Rooks oh there is Rook F3
d e yeah Rook G3 and then Rook G4 okay
oh we started yesterday yesterday
started yesterday a problem I was
inspired by what you said black can't
play Rook takes D2 yeah Rook D2 and then
we get something out of Van Forest
Nakamura but in order pick has gone a
completely different direction
that was not on my radar times a
thousand at all bro yeah I think if you
gave me 10 guesses probably the best
moves I mean this guy is just creating
art as we speak but you gotta love it
the arrow that you're just making
explains everything in the position uh
David the Deep on I cannot move which
means the D5 cannot open up the F7 Pawn
is super tender and now Now The Rook
lift ideas the other Rook joining into
the attack on E1 as well keeping the
pressure here by Noddy back yeah and
let's not be deceived by that evaluation
bar this is so dangerous for black if
you make one slip you might just be lost
as you say Tanya these pieces are very
actually very far away from the defense
of their King Fabi uses the Knight a
king's best friend to try and plug any
holes here maybe hinting that he might
capture this Pawn on a good day but
maybe just blocking some checks and now
what is the next step how does he put
more fuel on that fire I'm just a tour
of he wants to win here and now he wants
to end the tournament he wants to win uh
the chess kid Cup in this game and let's
remind everyone who might have just
joined us that if naughty back does win
this game with the white pieces it's a
position for all three results he wins
the Chaska cup he does lead the match
with one and a half points Fabiano
caruana doesn't only have to win set one
but also the Grand Final reset to take
the chess kit cup and as you were
talking about out of David the other
Rook has also come into the play bring
all the toys to the nursery yeah and I
love how every time Notre pick makes a
move the eval bar drops and then it kind
of creeps back up it's like that quote
you know first they ignore you then they
laugh at you then they fight you then
you win it's like his moves are that
deep but maybe Rook A1 is a mistake I
just don't know what Fabby does again
we're entering that situation where
Knight takes F4 may be possible it gets
really murky after G3 motor back really
posing some problems here practically of
course like even if you look at a
grandfather tao shout out to grandfather
Tao and the players that he has inspired
right with that being said of course
like if you look back it's house games a
lot of times you look at it with the
engine even a game that gives game six
with buffer Nick actually
um where he was actually losing that
game it's a sacrifice on F3 all this
craziness to happen it was actually a
bad move it was a bad sacrifice some of
them lots of them were not the greatest
sacrifices if you run it on the engine
but it was the Practical chances that he
gave there for is that me well that's
the one right there yeah they won well
ever take that picture you want to air
things yeah he won well we got one final
vote in for that yeah keep them coming
chat one of you will win the super cool
addings black wave plus device to
monitor your air quality where you're
playing some chess from and to make sure
that your performance is on the top of
the game you need that air things device
and right now Rook C7 black needs all
the pieces towards the king to try to
defense this Onslaught taking that pawn
on F4 just seems so dangerous for Fabi
to go into and the eval bar approves of
fabi's approach excellent defensive move
by Fabi defending the F7 Pawn he just
does what needs to be done in this
position trying to take the sting out of
White's battery and just tossing the
ball back into notrex court now he's got
to find another way to complicate The
Narrative maybe this is the time to play
E5 that pawn has stood on e4 a whole lot
longer than I thought it would maybe
it's time to advance it and change the
sort of scenery in the center I was
definitely thinking that E5 takes in an
F5 is that what we're looking at
E5 takes and an F5 and like you know you
got some stuff Ricky five there like
it's really nice it's very aggressive
obviously engines like yo this is not
the weight but of course it is
definitely practical there are lots of
ways you can go wrong we've already seen
it from Fabi here time and then like you
know psych part right now he's one game
away from elimination and this is a very
very hard position to face
you've got a talent oh does that work
you've got a talent for the sacrifices
there James that was nice sorry that's
ever made but yeah it looks like that
type of position you have to do
something a bit crazy uh you've kind of
burnt your Bridges there's no turning
back from here there's no reverse gear
just go all in just push pawns forward
try to get to that black king by hook or
by crook I'm really not capable of
understanding jokes about world
champions
it's really fishing
very good or something these guys are
killing it today
wow but so far ended it's not about
who's killing it but he is in the think
tank arrival Bar says that Fabi does
have the driver's seat one more time but
we can't emphasize enough that how much
how little that has actually meant in
the games between these uh uh two
players and we've seen on the back his
clutch he has been playing some
impressive some very impressive chess
this event and we see there four and a
half minutes on the clock there's a lot
of pressure on the board what move are
you expecting he doesn't look left do
you even do a cliff it's on the board
Rook H3 is a big threat what is the
response if black gets greedy I'm gonna
stop trying to predict any of Notre
bag's moves she always say he was really
Vishing for a tactics
stop it but Fabius called his wuff and
he played really quickly Pawn takes E4
he's probably gonna start hunting that
Queen although that probably means he's
not gonna do it he probably gonna play
Knight D2 to B1 for all we know that's
exactly right
I think he's actually getting ready to
sacrifice his Queen potentially Fabi in
this position if the white Rook does
slide across and start harassing her as
you say if the Rook comes across maybe
okay maybe you just slide but uh taking
this makes a lot of sense as well
because the black Rook enters the
position you've given up a queen but
you've got a rook Knight you've got a
powerful pawn and look at the white king
this one is just chaos on the board
right now he does have the option
however of Simply taking this pawn and
the game would go on here we go we are
the thing you're hearing the think tank
here a big time of age too as well for
Fabi here this could be his game but of
course I mean the other two could have
been his game too so it's really tough I
mean in order to be explaining out of
his mind
nice defense though we're defending F7
my D2 Knight is hanging
it's just this is not that easy at all
in case three he'll just take it and
look at you all crazy
shoot what do you do
it takes 24 yeah it's tough you might
have had to go with plan B there I think
you might have missed Queen takes H3
yeah
yeah tough position for updates tour but
he's making the best of it he's uh
simply recaptured he's only one Pawn
down he still has great chances against
that black king in Practical terms three
minutes though against almost seven
minutes it might be the clock that comes
back to haunt him later and decide this
game
really really tense stuff I think all
predictions are off at this point a
trade Bishop for Knight White's Bishop
maybe superior to the Black Knight so
some composition there long term hey you
know what that game he had where uh he
was playing Pawn F4 with the black
pieces I mean that game looked like it
was his game this one doesn't actually
it's not as clear that other one was
very clear but I mean hey we'll see Rook
D2 which is that's a dagger in the back
there well the other can't come down
just yet because you get mated on G8 but
it's just a nasty move that disrupts
White's coordination now you can't bring
the Rook up to F3 because of the check
on C1 potentially and queen F2 is mate
that's another nice one
and again we're in that situation where
norterbeck struggling to find a move
yeah just to show this Dania almost a
lawn mower Checkmate after The Rook
drops back boom check
and the queen cannot be taken due to the
pin and of course Checkmate in multiple
yeah
many items on the menu there
so if we start with check where does he
go Daniel what do we do after a check
because I want my ideas Rook C8
he's just losing but like what's the
move there Queen takes so I thought
about that King takes no Queen G4 I
think Forks the pawn on G2 yeah
that doesn't work just to show uh what
you guys are talking about as well after
check trying to deflect does walk into
this one nice what a move Checkmate and
this Rook wow now Rook D2 is a nasty
move boy she just set so many things up
because you hit the G2 Pawn so Queen G4
is always going to threaten mate and
motorbeck has to work around that he
just doesn't have a lot of space to work
with it should be one
retreating never feels nice
creeping around the edges and perhaps
the idea could be that he wanted to
vacate the E4 Square to get his Bishop
on there and defend the G2 Pawn in case
of all these ideas of uh black sliding
the queen to G4 threatening a mating one
and then James give a check bring that
Bishop keep the king safe is that
something that not about could be aiming
for
yeah definitely wants to put that Bishop
on e4 it's also a nice reroute because I
mean we may be able to get Bishop G6
here somehow in a perfect world somehow
especially if we check in like King G7
then Bishop takes G6 you may have to
take with the king so the pawn takes
Queen g8's mating right so you're
getting hit really hard there so you'll
be very careful about this stuff Bishop
takes King out in the middle of the
street here I mean literally this is GG
it has to be so rookie C1 oh my and it
was spotted immediately we have to have
an action replay there this position you
gotta chill out C1 dropping a rook down
onto the first rank deflecting away the
white Rook if it had been captured this
would have led to Checkmate on the G2
Square the white king trapped Fabian
spotted it instantly however of course
he had and he reacted by swinging the
white crew Queen across to the defense
and a couple more quick moves The Rook
was captured and the black queen has
dropped back wow right now Rook down to
D1 more trouble on the first rank you're
not the only one who can tactics not her
back so it's Fabiano with that move then
you has this game under control on the
clock on the board if he lets this one
slip that would be the craziest comeback
we've seen yet insane tactical Vision
there by Fabi the last few sequins and
moves that we're seeing building up on
that advantage and now a white
background feeling extremely uh tender
there with Rook D1 coming in and the one
big difference in The Narrative of this
match that we're seeing is that it's
Fabi who's got a five minute advantage
on the clock he has been getting great
positions with playing on seconds we've
seen that Advantage slip this time this
is his moment to strike in the match
notabeg jumps in with the Rook he's down
to a minute on the clock gives up that
Bishop before the Knight joins the
powerful attack black still doesn't have
time to go with the Rook to D1 you don't
want to pick it up with your king his
King G6 a move that you can consider
here
[Laughter]
for the
Queen Quincy five is even a movie of
that oh that's nice and then maybe
Queen C4
wow Daniel just no no or queen B5
because it hits the Rook on E8 oh wow
let's put this on the ball oh right
this is a check ignoring the bishop
ignoring their email bar doesn't love it
but it's a cool idea and then Queen to
B5 hitting the queen
yeah oh you're gonna get a queen end
game up a pawn so that's definitely on
the menu for Fabi yeah so just to show
Queen takes Queen looks like white is up
all the material in the world but when
you get back rank Checkmate uh
checkmated that is the end of the game
unfortunately so
if we see that on the board we that's
just everything I don't think I can take
any more of the tactics that we're
seeing the pieces being left hanging and
not recapturing this is absolutely wild
chess Bishop G6 the fact that fabi's
boss the good news for Fabi fans he's
got the time to burn right now will he
go for this absolutely crazy idea of
giving the check and then deflecting the
White Queen from the first rank or will
he simply pick up the bishop that's the
reason that Fabi goes into a thing what
are we predicting which line is he going
for he's calculating if he started Rook
C1 he's in the zone now Queen C5 Queen
B5 that's a sick that's just I don't
think so that's a signal it's a cool
line but I I think he's likelier to just
take back on G6 okay it's possible that
he's just trying to or he'll check on C5
and then pick up the bishop on G6 hard
to say though he's down to four minutes
and what is he picking up on G6 uh with
and that's really a question that's
perhaps not clear to a lot of us David
yeah you have three different viable
ways to recapture this white Bishop I
would be reluctant to take with the pawn
just because you open up the black king
to checks on the seventh rank maybe
that's fine too maybe that's playable
again reluctant instinctively to take
back this bishop with the black king you
never really want to lead from the front
with your king especially when there are
queen still on the board so the black
king advancing down the board would feel
counter-intuitive taken back with a
black queen it feels like the black king
is nice and safe but temporarily the
queen may be not on her best circuit on
her best Square
because it wasn't clear King G6 still
threatening Rook D1 I love it you're a
beast wow and it was the best move I'm
pretty sure
if it predicted it he's never seen that
of course so two
I mean I don't know what to call them
anymore we exhausted Geniuses I mean
Maniacs you know they say there's a fine
line between the two
oh man
oh
now it looks like full control for black
the problem for white is you're stuck
you're just fixed on your own first rank
there's no way to kind of just activate
your pieces suddenly because Black's
pieces are staring down at this white
king and the pawns around it feels like
at the right moment Fabi will start
launching the other pawns don't forget
about those two on the queen side they
look like they've not participated in
the game there we go these pawns will
act as a distraction while actually the
white pieces are just simply tied down
yeah the White Queen at some point will
be overworked it's unlikely she'll ever
be able to go and capture any of those
pawns because there will always be
checkmating motifs later in the game he
could just resign in a few moves here I
mean B5 A5 everything five just push it
all the way through and there's a that
is very nice very nice display here
probably I mean there's no way you could
lose this right there's just no possible
way right we've said that before today
yeah yeah but this time again there's
just no ideas there's no defensive ideas
you can't bring your Rook up to E3
because it just gets pushed right back
down with Rook D1 black black structure
showing who the papa is here and not a
back makes a very important useful move
clears up the back rank so now he can
start thinking about freeing up the
queen and the Rook H3 was the need of
the other hair it was however the black
queen is going to find an even more
beautiful Square most likely she's just
gonna step one square down even further
into the white and then it's gonna step
one square down
oh rookie four H5 don't you even think
about it nice A4 E4 rookie four what a
tricky move by Notre back tricky chicky
let's not rule him out he saved crazy
oppositions than this one the difference
I guess is a few pieces on the board
maybe some stalemate tricks at the end
of this game yeah
wow and there are big threats on the
board The Rook can slide in and attack
the BlackRock can slide in and attack
the queen and the F5 Pawn a lot of ideas
all over right now not a back in
desperation tries to create some
weaknesses on the queen side the eval
bar loves Black's position Fabi in
driver's seat guys do you think this is
it this is the one that he levels the
match in I think so I think this is the
one this is the one here and then he's
gonna have to win again though it is
tough it's very tough then again
thanks Tanya right great job you know
and then you got to win again though
like all right cool thanks guys
wow
wow it is a Herculean task for Fabiano
caruana but not the back is down to just
30 seconds on the clock
yeah we've seen it before though
notibeck is so quick so good so tricky
uh I think it's more about Fabi at this
point it's Fabi who can kind of Let Us
slip it's Fabby who can uh kind of mess
this up so if he finds the Right Moves
In the next two or three turns I think
it's over no matter what nodemex time
situation is even if he had three hours
it wouldn't be enough I mean even if
Fabio wins the win order book defense he
just uses every last
nanoparticle in his position the Apon he
uses even that to create problems for
Fabi but fabi's just undeterred Rook E4
is very likely then what's the finishing
blow H5 yeah Rook takes eight four and
then you have to find that one more move
Queen B3 oh yeah but now Rook G4 check
oh Queen F4 goes up the Rook some threat
to Perpetual even Checkmate geez bro not
again not again I'm telling you right
now if this man gets out of this one
we're getting at it I'm gonna take you
off the mic you know I'm out of here I'm
done for the day because that might be
that the match might be yeah exactly
for the day
we gonna be done for real for the day
guys
I mean I can't really explain fabi's
move other than just pure panic just why
would you ever bring the black queen
away from uh pinning down the white
pieces the white King was the one
getting checkmated now suddenly the
black king is defenseless
you're staying at the Ritz Carlton
you're saying that I'd rather stay at
the motel eight like Queen had to stay
on G3 to limit the threats goodness and
here comes the time again this is time
and time again his time has got him time
and time again D1 and H5 but then rookie
three and you could probably get mated
here you could lose your Rook to a fork
probably gotta move bro we need to move
here we go again we need help from the
engine here has Fabi got one or two
moves to keep the advantage or is it
just wow okay he does have a few moves
to stay in this one and
he's gonna find it surely he's given a
check I've got to do it gotta cover the
G4 square but every key three ideas
Rook D3 but that loses The Rook man get
out of here like rookie three to G3 11
seconds oh my god dude come on rookie
three root form at least this time a man
get in great positions
okay that didn't work
do you want coming in because of that
move
oh after the tour of he went for the
pawn rather than Checkmate I think in
Practical terms
step out just start running with the
white king nine seconds pretty safe on
H4
is back in the game
how do you win though what what's the
move how do you win you go around to E5
no H4 now from this queen exchanges now
Queen traits do help Abdu sator of he's
going to hold the drawers no but H4 was
winning there I think there were no
checks after Queen G4 but now we now he
plays H4 10 seconds
he knows he's so close that was relief
on fabi's face that's it
my goodness
still playing he wants a stalemate he
wants King H5 and H4 and we have seen a
fortress before in these positions but
not this one because the a pawn is alive
and Fabiano caruana they're with the
confidence he wins this game three it is
what needed to be done and there we see
he leaves he knows he's got a big game
for coming up and after such of he
shakes his head he was so close to
saving this one we've got a match on our
hands with the final fourth rapid game
coming up but this one David it was a
wild ride this was a wild ride and uh we
were holding off on any predictions
until the very final seconds actually
notabeck fought back from a hopeless
position and here if he had traded
Queens by sliding back forcing the
Queens off the board he might have had
some chance of saving that end game
instead he took the pawn and he was
punished The Black Queen slid back she's
coming in and we saw the killer blow a
few moves later after repeating was this
move point forward check and after the
king captured this Pawn it had walked
into the Firing Line This was a nasty
pin and the White Queen was lost game
over a fantastic tactic there by uh
Fabiano caruana ending the game it has
been a roller coaster match so far the
first game the only peaceful one and
then two decisive results not a pack
takes game two Fabiano takes a game a
three and the action continues with the
final game coming up right after this
twitch break
[Music]
at Magnus Academy we've taught chess to
a hundred thousand kids with Summer
around the corner we're gearing up for
camps
at online chess camps kids learn about
Chess in a safe fun environment from a
team of All-Star coaches
kids are grouped by skill level from
beginners up to national champions there
are never more than eight kids per coach
so every child gets plenty of attention
you might even get the chance to meet
Magnus and ask him a question or
challenge him to a game
each week has a different theme like
opening traps learning from your losses
or Magnus Carlson's best games
sign up by May 31st to get a 30 discount
join the 100
000 Kids and Counting that have learned
chess with Magnus chess Academy
foreign
[Music]
chess is great for the brain but it's
also fun to play and chess kid makes it
easy to have fun whether your child is a
total beginner or a prodigy they can hop
on and find a well-matched opponent from
around the world at any time chess kid
is the safe parent-approved way for your
child to play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest bustles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids chess kit is
easy whether you're a parent helping
your child a coach managing dozens of
kids or a school of hundreds signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
for over 75 years we've witnessed
moments that will last forever
records and trophies first and only game
changing Innovations from the heroes we
admire to the joy of watching them play
our history defines us and inspires us
and pushes us into the future
celebrating 75 years of changing the
game
Puma forever faster
an aerofocus concentration performance
air things put you in control of air
pollutants that cloud your work from
home space shifting your state with
every breath
find your air of clarity now
[Music]
thank you
our Meetup Community is constantly
growing we are at 20 000 members and you
can become a part of it start your own
Community your own a group with Meetup
in your city visit meetup.com chess for
all the details to get your community
growing in the Chess World and right now
we're gonna meet up with Simon Williams
because it's been mind-boggling chess
action Simon yeah it has indeed and a
quick update on division two and this is
the big match between the big fish
fedexv and mamajarov so two big hitters
now mamajorov after three games in the
four game match was one uh point up but
we come to the current position and we
see that fedisev with the black pieces
in a must-win situation has a very good
chance to win this game and the reason
he has a good chance to win is the
bishop is so dominating it can work on
both sides of the board being a long
range piece White's Knight has to only
stay on one side of the board Black's
also got this pawn two squares away from
queening so if fedexv manages to convert
this position which I feel should be
winning you just got to bring the black
king up to support uh your Pawn if FedEx
can win that it will go to Armageddon
and if fedesef wins the Armageddon he is
champion of division two he gets ten
thousand dollars so even come even
bigger fish and he gets a place in
division one and that's probably the
most important thing getting that place
with the big boys I'm saying big a lot
now so we better we better just leave it
I think at this point of what before I
say big again it's a big tournament in a
big place and uh we got some big
presenters and let's go back to the big
presenters in the middle
uh but in common so much for that big
update on division two we've got a big
game four coming up as Fabiano caruana
will start with the white pieces we have
been seeing such aggressive chess by
both these players it's been a fantastic
nail-biting match so far if Fabi wins
this game with white we will have a
grand final reset in case of a draw we
get to see a bidding Armageddon if not a
back wins he takes the championship the
action started and we've got a sicilian
another rosalima on the board of course
and it's a total repeat so far of the
game two games ago and will Notre Beck
come up with an improvement because
there he was suffering out of the
opening but it's Fabi who chooses a
different Retreat Square for his bishop
and that is the more common move Bishop
F1 is considered the main line now
they're following a line that has been
well known for many years white pink
generally brings the queen back to D1 at
some point and either goes for the
direct D4 or the way Fabi is playing at
Knight D2 Queen D1 and then the Knight
coming from D2 to F3 is what I remember
but that was around you know the time
that George Washington was President so
I'm sure the theory has changed quite a
bit since then that's exactly what I
remember too yeah and that's maybe what
Fabio remembers yeah clearly uh Fabi
following those long trodden Parts he's
going to bring that white knight
towards his King he's going to try and
step forward in the center at the right
moment white has the bishop pair but
that's very much long term it's more
about a fight for the Central School
Theory hasn't changed since 1799 kid
nice there was a novelty in 1801
actually
Benjamin Franklin
wow and before this heats up because we
know it will that's just how this match
is going I will predictions on this
panel is this match going is this set
one going into an Armageddon David
well three days ago
abducator struck first in game two he
won he was immediately pegged back he
lost to Fabi but then he won game four
of their match and progressed so I'll
back up to satorov even though he's got
black and I don't really like his
position wow another historic fact there
by David James what do you think I got a
bag father here and a reason for that is
because okay every game he's had some
chances and sometimes it just takes like
some not warming up but like filling out
the opponent it takes a few games
sometimes you're down in the match
sometimes you down 3-0 now of course in
this way you would lose but you could be
down a few games and then you can also
come back all right I got it I know what
to do now or let me make these changes
cool gotcha and then you know we'll have
an Armageddon so well I'm gonna say
probably once oh we'd love to see an
Armageddon Daniel we would but in the
immortal words of David Howell nor
Rebecca's black and I don't like his
position I'm going for Abby
all right well Fabi has made a lot of
bond moves in this position especially
directing and hinting at play on The
Queen side uh David you've got to
explain that to us does he plan to gain
more space on uh queenside yeah I think
actually this last movie is just guarded
against blacks ideas as well so if we
jump into the position and uh if we
rewind just one move Fabi played pawns
A3 that might look mysterious but it's
guarded against the opponent's ideas he
very much wanted his own plan of
stepping forward in the center however
after a trade he does have to be alert
to potential night jumps the Knight
could jump into the C2 from where it
would Fork this white rook and the white
rook in the corner so with that in mind
with his opponent's activity uh he wants
to prevent it and he pushes his Pawn to
A3 so very much preemptive and uh not
nordeback doesn't react he just pushes
his Rook across one square
I'll ask you the question do you want to
step forward now and Fabi says no he
first wants to prepare a nice home for
his Bishop potentially on G2 and this is
all about maneuvering I'm struggling to
explain these ones the Black Knight
might want to jump into the center
trading this white knight maybe black
will push on this side of the ward but
Fabi takes the opportunity to push the H
Pawn now that the Black Knight has uh
vacated the king side maybe aiming to
loosen up Black's King slightly James
it's also this I'm always a fan of H4
definitely was not expecting it I will
say that but definitely always a fan to
see it you do want to play H5 and we
live he plays it instead right then our
idea here was to play H5 take on G6 and
maybe even play King G2 actually put the
Rook on H1 at some point or Bishop H3
all kind of ideas but he plays H5 so now
maybe we can plant a piece on G5 at some
point maybe we go Bishop H3 you don't
have a light Square bishop and then try
to put the Knight on G5 because you
can't kick me out of there there are
some things we can do there maybe push
G4 it's very aggressive and then try to
get H5 in at some point this is
attacking one on one but H5 on the board
here let's see how Fabi responds
both players play incredibly quickly
down here do you think this is part of
their preparation is this a setup that
I'm just a tourism has prepared because
it looks strange to me yeah he might
have prepared the sort of General ideas
of the setup I'm sure that they're both
out of preparation in the specific
position but Black's plan in this line
is generally pretty straightforward I
think we mentioned it B5 and B4 just
kind of driving the pawn down trying to
shatter a white structure Fabi was
trying to operate on the king side maybe
we'll now switch his attention to the
center D4 is still possible so very
flexible a lot of plans really for both
sides black doesn't even have to play B5
black can also play D5 so both Pawn
structures are very flexible here I
still prefer white though he's got
somewhat more space and of course the
bishop pair and he's just made a Tempo
move forcing the queen out of its
initial Square yeah really nice move
there just again asking the question
yeah I guess it could be blocked by the
black Bishop but just asking a question
for nordeback where you're gonna move
your queen
and yeah still very balanced
can I Retreat can I retract my statement
about uh nodabeck taking this game it
feels a bit shaky for black he does
block I would not trade Bishops here how
about you guys yeah no no maybe Queen D2
it was like develop a little bit more if
you trade it's on your terms then yeah
exactly maybe bishop F4 Target the D6
spawn ask another question
you know usually you want to keep your
Bishop especially if you have a bishop
pair they tend to work better in tandem
so keeping them on the board makes sense
but also notabeck would have to spend a
couple of moves trading off and the
black king would lack any Defenders if
the black dark Square Bishop disappears
so
no right or wrong answer here it's just
a matter of taste it feels like
and that goes for all the flexible ideas
that both sides have in their up their
sleeve right now
so tense you can kind of feel the nerves
nodded back sitting back sipping some
water
can he recover from that previous defeat
losing with white when you're on the
brink of tournament Victory it's hard
it's heartbreaking
he usually has his head in hand he's
leaning forward and after what we saw in
game three one would expect more of that
but it looks like he's
he's found his rhythm and is that also
because the position is just quieter
compared to what we've been seeing in
the last three games yeah for once the
position is just kind of chill and both
players can chill out a little bit at
least for a couple of moves until it
gets chaotic again because the moment
black plays D5 or B5 there will be some
direct confrontation eventually right
now there's been kind of maneuvering
play for the last 10 moves or so but
speaking of non-maneuvering play there's
the first declaration of war D4 has been
played by Fabi so he is not against a
bishop trade if it occurs on his own
terms
D4 starts the war wow big move 54 for
the score okay for the war for the score
right we want more before we want more
chess we want armageddon's we want uh
reset but uh yeah how would we react
with black here because suddenly a lot
of tension and it feels like it's up to
Black to at least release something will
you trade pawns will you trade Bishops
anything else productive to do my
instinct was to take on D4 take on G5
and then actually play E5 and try to
Target some of those dark squares in the
center but that's just one of like 15
different ways that you can play of
course whites I thought would take with
a pawn but now that I look at it maybe
he wants to take with a knight then
there's Queen B6 kind of forks the two
pawns probably not a big problem but all
of that has to be assessed and evaluated
if H takes G5 then I definitely want to
go E5 and try to carve out some of those
dark squares
what I definitely wanted to do at that
moment was take a screenshot of what we
had because Fabiano caruana and not the
back of the Satchel were absolutely
twinning with their chest pose and that
reminds me to tell all our chat to start
pausing and sending your selfies of
watching this match between these two
Titans of the game the chess get cups
send us your best photos and we will
pick a winner to win the athings black
wave plus device which will help you
monitor your air quality to up your
chest performance and talking about
upping the chest performance both
players are upping the ante in this game
some trades on G5 and the fact that Fabi
has slowed down it means he's actually
considering taking it with the H Pawn
or considering taking away the Knight
depending on what his first intention
was
Arguments for both you normally want to
take with the Knight I guess activate a
piece Black's King side a bit fragile
but if you take with the pawn you do
have a kind of a dark Square bind
tactics either way Daniel you mentioned
there's kind of some forcing lines so
these players base their decisions on
calculation E5 and D5 both sensible
candidate moves here I love it I love
that he's again gone for the most direct
approach Knight G5 was my natural pick
the moment that trade was offered with
hg5 of course Fabi 2.0 we've been
talking about it the most aggressive
option on the board how does that change
the Dynamics in the position now David
well it means that long term white does
have to be slightly wary of the fact he
has double Pawns
also his pawns on Dart squares and I
think as Daniel mentioned there we go
black is fighting for those dark squares
now white has a light squared Bishop so
long term doing well on that color
complex but if the Black Knights start
entering if they start jumping forward
on Dart squares if that white G5 Pawn
the double Pawn gets picked off yeah
it's uh it's just gonna become very very
complex I'm liking the way that this is
progressing for neuterberg suddenly it
feels like Fabi might have lost his way
a little bit
can I go back to my prediction yeah yeah
I can feel that actually I mean after I
really want to get like I like the Jeep
on I love the Jeep on there but then I
mean I don't have the right piece
configuration to complement the G Bond
on G5 so of course D5 here is something
I do want to play and then gain the
tempo there eventually my plan is to
play Queen D2 Knight H2 and play G4 or
even play Queen D2 G4 first let them
take then play Knight H2 take on G4 get
a knight to H6 or F6 this is a nice plan
but of course it can be parried in a few
ways I think maybe like Knight f8 to H7
which I have to be very very careful of
how fast I move this like there's things
that you can do but I mean we'll see
what he does I definitely like the pawn
on G5 but if we don't configure the
right pieces it's going to be a weakness
rather than an asset and Daniel I know
where you want to jump this Knight into
yeah I'm thinking about a knight D4 but
I don't know if it's necessary I think
the ideas that James mentioned black is
cramped but a space Advantage isn't
really a tangible Advantage you know
it's like cryptocurrency eventually you
have to convert it into real money and I
just don't see a compelling plan for
white White's got individual moves that
are attempting Bishop H3 another one
move threat black and move is Rook away
from C8 no big deal so I think
objectively I agree with the eval bar
probably around equal but the trend of
the game seems to favor notabeck Knight
D4 though definitely a viable candidate
move has to be considered look at his
time Fabi down a lot of time here yeah
we're talking he's thinking still
thinking in fact yeah I just want to
point out the reason this is definitely
possible is because after the night
trade this Pawn hangs so if you do
capture Black's new passport in the
middle of the board then the G5 Pawn
drops and suddenly I do see this Knight
jumping in this Pawn pushing forward and
this bishop is it better than the Black
Knight I'm not so sure so uh really big
decision here for Fabi he could maintain
the tension he could uh I don't know
take this Pawn or could move his Bishop
out but uh some big threats against this
guy and remember the G5 Pawn in the next
few moves maybe he doesn't have too much
Choice actually uh difficult position
suddenly for Fabi and that's reflected
in his clock times four minutes down now
his recipe for Success the reason he won
the previous game he was ahead on the
clock the whole time suddenly Rose
reversed yet again
I mean this is a huge time age I mean
this is probably the biggest time Edge
we've seen in this match so far and
we've seen it of course when time got
low Fabi definitely did not have the
best end of it except in the last game
it's time to get a low law but he was
able to convert there right at the right
moment here but he doesn't have another
chance to slip up in the time um and
allow anything for norterbeck but it is
crucial you need to think you got to
find the right plan so you can continue
this game on and he does understand and
this is crucial that's why he's taking
his time here but he can't take too much
time I mean he's almost at six minutes
here
almost half the time yeah he needs to
speed up three minutes on one move
that's fine you can afford that type of
thing but
yeah he's gotta hope he's seen far
enough into the future and moment of
truth either black steps back with the
Knight to a safe square and the game
will take on a kind of maneuvering phase
as James said white might start
attacking on the king's side or he jumps
in after page three was what I was
afraid of okay never mind did I said
anything Notre bag had this planned
seven years ago yeah
when he was like three years old yeah he
was already considering this position
that he would get like a basketball Cup
Final in 2023. I did all before and
Blacksburg Dives in defending that key
Pawn on D4 Black's Queen now also aiming
at G5 you have to keep defending the
Black Knight the Black Knight if it if
it gets the uh time the Tempe to jump
into the center I think this is turning
in Black's favor
wow turning in not a back's favor and
the clock is already in his favor he's
got almost twice the amount of time as
Fabi does and we've seen that to become
a big factor in those critical moments
so I'll be down to about six and a half
minutes with that black knight jumping
into the dark squares he wants none of
it trades it off will pick up the D4
Pawn but the Rook can jump into C3 and
start attacking the other pawns starting
to smell that distinct smell of
Armageddon the more pieces get traded
you know I can see a world coming up to
E3 there's another pair
I don't know might be moving in that
direction yeah if I can take your
prediction back to come after the storm
the last few games have been so uh just
yeah they need to timeout but it's only
going to get crazier with army but I
still like black I think blacks black
has the upper side of equality here as
tall would say black is more equal
[Laughter]
all right well this one will be a grind
and it looks like not a backup do such
trouble is the one who has that slight
push in the position and let's also
remind everyone that Fabi has to win two
sets to take the chess kit cup it just
keeps getting aggressive the moment we
think that the dust has settled E5 again
fireworks
yeah I'm just starting to wonder what if
noderbeck takes everything and plays
Rook D3 I know David you probably have
the same question on the tip of your
tongue yeah is this just important
sacrifice support no you wanted it you
think so just wanted a pawn oh my God
this might be wow this is very serious
wow he's just Advanced Fabi we talked
about this position we slightly
preferred black because black has a very
safe King Black's Rook is very active
and black has an outside majority long
term safety of King very important and
Fabi decided okay to go for it now but
after a capture simple capture the plan
must be to retake this Pawn but after
everything comes off the board are you
gonna defend David the Deep one here
it's just gonna he's doomed you don't
you don't defend it and look at fact
that he was stretching he's definitely
seen this line and we're seeing it
happen on the board the trades will he
find Rook D3 hitting and winning that D5
Pawn it's on the board wow that was a
huge huge huge mistake by Fabby who
basically
I don't want to catastrophize but this
is kind of a catastrophe yeah that could
be the end of the tournament that one
kind of hasty Pawn push we always say it
pawns don't move backwards and suddenly
this d-pawn it looks so strong one move
ago but it's being rounded up White's
Rook just not quick enough to join the
action he rushed it he could have taken
a prep uh kind of preparation move but
suddenly is there any hope if the Queens
come off Rook end game might be hopeless
the problem here is the G5 Pawn 2 as
well like okay we grab one Pawn but then
like you know oh a Ponders and say the
game's over but also you have another
weak Pawn on G5 too as well we also have
the two versus one on that side and your
down time so if you combine all these
together and the psych part I just
dropped the pawn oh snap you know
especially when you drop something in an
intense match a lot of times you get mad
at yourself too right it's a lot of
things going on with fiber right now
this could be very very bad yeah the
turns on things are looking bad for
popular
piano slow down he has to he has taken
moment in this position and we'll use
this time to check in with ginger tea um
Simon Williams Simon big action in
division two as well that's right yeah
in division two we're going to the
Armageddon game and uh this is could
could decide the whole thing in the
Armageddon situation mamajarov has to
win to take it to another mini match if
managerov doesn't uh draw or win in the
Armageddon game that means we have a
champion in feder7 it does look just
looking at a position that mamajarov
will win that game so they're gonna have
to play two more games after that
division three Alan uh picture has won
that division as well he did defeat
Harry Krishna so lots of results coming
in wow this is the
actually chose won the bid and chose
black
he's got he had the black pieces and um
it just looks like he's going to win a
piece in that Armageddon game and that
means he's won the first stage of the
match it will go to another mini match
where uh anything can happen again there
wow chakra mom made hero of making his
comeback in a division two going from
the losers bracket he is playing
Fellowship of that match is hot and this
one as well a big moment for Fabi not a
big Abdul satrov with the black pieces
has all the advantage is winning the
pawn how difficult is this for Fabi to
hold
extremely he's also six and a half
minutes down on the clock no obviously
not Rebecca's not going to take on D5
with the queen and get mated this might
be fabi's last hurray get that Rook to
C8 and start praying
going for the counter attack the problem
is I think black has a very effective
way to deal with any threats against his
own King if we jump in white has just
landed a check don't block with the
black queen because you will get
skewered along the eighth rank instead
if you simply move your king I'm not
sure which Square G7 H7 they look the
same if the white Rook comes up you're
trying to attack from behind but black
is the first to give a check the white
king will move and black can land this
punch and you're hitting the pawn the
key here is that you defend along the
diagonal this is typical in many
positions if you have a bishop on this
diagonal Queen on this diagonal your
king is Never Ever Getting mated and
it's black who arrives first the
Armageddon smell has dissipated a little
bit that's a stunning spot to put the
queen on D4 and it's so instructive for
chess kids all over the world to look
for that Central Square for your pieces
because that's where they're the most
powerful yeah and uh actually in just
chess in general I have very rarely seen
someone as talented as a tour of in
Queen end games he's defeated Magnus
Carlsen twice in Queen end games in the
world rapid and in tata steel earlier
this year just the way he manipulates
the queen he always seems to find the
best squares when I play Queen and games
I'm just guessing I'm just like the
queen looks okay here this looks like a
decent check but after this tour if he
knows where to put his Queen and he's
already foreseen with this last sequence
of moose that uh he can attack and
defend at the same time with the queen
in the middle of the bud
no answers I mean you can go back to F4
but again that allows that Queen trade
you talked about that's exactly what is
likely to happen and
that pond construction on the king side
is Kind of Perfect at deterring
Perpetual checks now I'm not convinced
that Rook D1 is the easiest path you can
also trade Queens with Queen F5 so some
decisions to be made here for notorite
I'm actually liking the look of Queen F5
here given the weakness of the Pawn on
G5 what about queenies
and then he just picks up the pawn
doesn't it
can I just take on G5 oh we're actually
seven you said okay Network C8 Queen E7
Works C7 I like your auditions maybe you
put it on this Quest so you don't get
hit oh so yeah okay yeah about a sick
same idea and uh basically the idea is
just yours I've stolen your idea of
piggybacking uh piggybacking off your
idea just winning this Pawn basically
pick up the pawn it is very weak but
queen of five is also nice too as well
he's got so much time to figure this out
yeah yeah the the only question kind of
the big question now is do you go for a
queen trait or a rook trade as you said
Daniel The Rook trade also looks very
healthy very winning the king moves and
then you kind of centralize your queen
maybe you put it back here the king can
laid out in the corner there's never
going to be checks and then you start
advancing
this looks like it should be winning two
but Queen end game's tricky uh the
alternative and maybe the one I would go
for as well just because I'm a scaredy
cat get the Queen's off you'll never get
checkmated and uh the two buses one over
here should win this Pawn week two
yeah for choice too many options for
another back or look winning right now
Burger the pasta the pizza he's got to
make a decision eventually and these are
nerve-wracking moments because you know
that if you make the wrong decision you
might be giving your opponent
unnecessary chances to recover
yeah are you a pasta Burger
what kind of guy Kebab what do we have
we had burgers and pasta here we had a
little bit of everything so it's been
good we're talking about food or I might
not start eating the computer
[Laughter]
oh man Queen the eight on the board
there there's removed David and with the
same idea you found it yeah Queen d8 was
better than Queen E7 that was the best I
mean this guy's just a scientist mixing
his chemicals it's crazy Sheen yeah
trust me Queen end games with this guy
it's just just resign just press the
resign button in-game Queens resign who
that reminds me of Magnus Carlsen also
known for just how strong he is in these
Queen end game positions precise
maneuvering finding the right squares
one of the hardest kind of positions to
play and the action that you were
calling out Rook Rook jumps to C7
attacks that F7 Pawn not the back
offensive he always meets defense with
offense in two moves he's just turned it
around the F7 was Under Fire and now for
Fabi F2 under attack centralization in
Queen end games uh you called it Tanya I
think Magnus is the best Queen end game
specialist in history but Abdul store
has beaten him twice in Queen end games
like what can he say about that that's
all you need to know and there's some
cool tactics actually on the board right
now if white drops his Rook back you can
take this white Pawn on G5 right now if
you want to be cynical I mean you can
keep the tension you can probably come
in but just take this Pawn eliminate any
danger and is he gonna play it now you
drop in with a check double attack and
you pick up nobody could solve this in
his mother's womb he will he sees that
move he's just trying to decide whether
to play it or to play Rook F3 yeah
everything wins at this point it feels
like even if you do much before or even
probably yeah H4 H4 doesn't work push
everything he's about to make a decision
and I don't know if you guys saw it but
that look on his face it was
determination it was focus and he was
calculating deciding the paths that he
wants will he keep the tension build the
pressure or pick up that second Pawn we
will be finding out uh in seconds and
meanwhile for Fabiano caruana the
troubles don't end on the board he down
to two and a half minutes he's got to
save a very difficult position
I said I wanted more chess but this is
going to be the final game of the chess
kick up absolutely
you might resign after Rook takes G5 and
queen end game down two pawns like this
there's just no hope because you're not
even you know within a mile of Perpetual
at any time
wow noted back again good tip for all
the chess kids out there he sat on his
hands he didn't move and then he
calculated double checked made sure
there were no blunders and he went for
it two points up now now we're a G3 on
there
H4 I mean this is this is uh over here
last moment final nail in the coffin wow
see it on fabi's face he knows it's over
he's done so well he's fought so hard
but do satorf just inspired in this game
who defeated a Fabi in the Winner's
semi-final knocking him down into the
loser's bracket Fabi fighting his way
through that and coming back on a top to
fight for the championship but not a
backup disorder of after an up and down
game is Just minutes away from the
Chaska cup win the most debilitating
thing he's got seven and a half minutes
on his clock he's got a wagon load of
time to deal with anything that Fabby
throws at him with every ticking second
Fabby coming closer and closer to
accepting the hopelessness of the
situation he takes on G5 he might
deliver a couple more checks but this is
basic Betty at this point
yeah the black queen just needs to find
a square from where she can protect all
her pawns the black King's Super safe no
checks on that one and yeah the black
pawns will start advancing on the queen
side past Pawn will be created it might
still take a while but uh the results
shouldn't be in doubt at this point to
Satori if he's done everything right the
mental fortitude coming back from a
defeat in the previous game to outplay
one of the world's best players with
black lose with weight win with blacks
without the Masters do it but they do it
this way it's what they teach in the
Soviet school yes exactly that's the
expression that I was looking for I mean
back to home base
B5 is next
yeah let's play B5 here
spawns
quite easy in game now of course you can
study these end games a lot Deborah
esky's in-game manual I mean the queen
ones I I've never actually touched that
chapter in fact I think he's gonna play
A5 no just kidding hey five oh my gosh
no no that's not a difficult moment far
Fabiano caruana and we're also getting a
big update that Federal save Vladimir
fry to save has one division two a big
congratulations to Big Fish he has been
on fire he wins a ten a thousand dollars
and punches his ticket to the next event
uh division one or the next event of the
Champions Chester that means that we've
got four players confirmed for the next
event already it's Fabiano caruana not a
backup dosatrov Jordan van forest and
big fish joins them
to line up better safe is a player
nobody will complain about when he's in
division one he's so fun to watch he's
not over 2700 at the moment but he he
was 27 30 and he still plays like that
online and in the rapid time control
just gonna be so fun to watch him play
the play the greats
he also almost bihikaru in there and and
the last one too as well and he did beat
him in a World Cup before Oh yes very
strong player and we're getting more
winners coming through as it is Alan
Pisha in division three who takes down
Hari Krishna wins division three so he
goes back with five thousand dollars and
the action is still on and this one but
it looks like this will not be going
into the Armageddon that is two extra
pawns and exposed King for Fabiano
caruana jaw is a far away dream right
now for him D5 get those utensils out go
for the kill we're a couple seconds away
from crowning a winner this is exquisite
technique as we've come to expect
amazing white wishes he could pick up
the port next to his king throw it off
the board because then there might be
stalemate ideas oh that's uh yeah at
this moment Checkmate is incoming
Black's two pawns up white can give a
couple of spite checks but they are
easily blocked easily dealt with
that's it
says out of ideas Queen E4 King steps up
to H6 and then the F1 can block a sixth
rank check after Queen C6 F6 correct
King H6 anyway
yeah yeah
easy stuff just close the Box around the
white king a pawn check will do the
business as well I think although you
want to be careful of some stalemate
there yeah
just move the black king forward the
white king is going to be forced up the
board so take away the Escape squares
that seems to be good wisdom in this
position Abdus tour of I think he's
going to show it to us right now he's
going to show us the uh easiest
technique maybe G4 Lincoln H6 almost
works right G4 King H4 King H6 there's
no stalemate is there exactly because if
Queen makes his mate but creepy six
chicken suddenly white would win wall
where is this actually even in this
position we've just been talking
we've been talking about this move
shutting the door threatening Checkmate
but white forces the Queen's off and
white wins thank God man before and then
bro that sucks I'm just gonna be totally
honest I probably wouldn't see that in
five years until he pointed it out it
took me a long time as well got to admit
what a nasty trap that by Fabiano just
moving that Queen inviting that king
move forward not about the fact that
he's slowed down that's good news for
him or or he's deciding between King H6
and G4 and King H6 and he hasn't seen it
at all that would be the craziest Moment
In online chess what a trick from Fabi
if we see King H6 we've seen it all oh
my God so what is the move right each
floor still can maybe just Retreat The
Black Queen now I'm scared I'm scared of
getting checked
queen of six just get that Queen back
closer to the King stop threatening the
pawn Advance then keep everything under
control but knocking at six that would
be
the weirdest thing that could happen the
white or maybe not we've seen crazy
things today
he goes King G7 oh I saw that king move
away from H7 my heart left out of my
chest
but there's no direct threat because G4
still doesn't mate and if a Fabi was to
pick up that A6 spawn she's gonna do
oh then this is counter player he has
done certainly white has a past Pawn so
now you pretty much have to deliver
Checkmate if you're black perfectly done
Queen B7 King H6 now works and if King
takes H5 there's Queen F5 to G5
beautiful beautiful stuff that's it
beautiful that's it he figured it out
now that's it yeah Checkmate is
threatened and no way to deal with that
just to show Danny's idea a check now
force of the white king back and the
king is trapped note how white now has a
past a pawn so there's never any
stalemate ideas five and G5 and the pawn
delivers the mate okay he could have
done that
that's happening Queen D2 is that the
winning move
and that's it we have a winner not a bag
of the central wins the chess kid cup
Fabiano caruana resigns a mate in one
and there he is what a dream run it has
been winning division two of the
chassisable Masters qualifying for
division one of the chest good cup and
this chess kit was Unstoppable in this
tournament a huge congratulations David
what a match performance this was
it's incredible to believe he's still a
teenager he is scarily good he played
fantastically he deserves it he's been
the most consistent player throughout
the week notes of Steel we have a
champion we do have a champion and that
means it is not available
and today he was the better player
he was the better player Fabi fought
well there were some genius moments from
both sides right James absolutely genius
moments of course I mean Fabi had a
chance every single game but the
resourcefulness of course the fighting
that he had there he had a little bit of
everything Universal something that you
see obviously Magnus do very good stuff
from the do Satora yeah and Fabi fought
to the last second literally to the last
move he would have had me fooled but
Notre back it takes a lot more than that
to fool him he wasn't fooled at all this
tournament amazing play consistent play
great opening play I'm just excited to
see him in the Norway Masters yeah this
is such a big confidence boost for him
and it was his debut in division one of
the Champions Chester and he gets it
done the first time around James first
time around I mean right one up one down
clown right of course he wins the
cheskick cup and the kid if not not
technically not a kid but at the same
time he wins the chess game Cup first
time around there's a lot to see from
norterbeck another big feather inadevac
Abdul satyros uh already super
impressive Korea he is just 18 years old
he is the former World rapid champion in
2021 and he he's here joining us after
that incredible match congratulations
naughty back
thank you
you were playing today against one of
the best players in the world and you
took it in set one how did you do it
yeah it was a really tough match I think
he had a very good chance to beat me
um because he was getting very good
positions out of the opening and uh
okay he he was uh he outplayed me in the
in game two I guess
uh but uh I was a I was lucky to
uh find some good moves and uh it was a
uh after I think he missed D6 Knight A3
and then I I took the initiative
and I come I managed to convert it very
well I guess
uh yeah in the game three he just uh
surprised me in the opening I think
Knight E7
uh okay he's uh it was a surprise for me
and uh
I think he got very good position out
the opening and then I got some some
kind of attack
but uh it's
it wasn't enough
so yeah and uh yeah at the end I think I
got some chances to draw but
uh it was very tough and I was very long
time and yeah it was very difficult and
I just plundered
yeah in game four I think it was a very
good game by me uh the only game that I
I can be
uh some are proud of but uh
but but yeah it was very difficult match
obviously it was a very difficult match
and some very up
um yeah I was
kind of confident because I managed to
beat him uh earlier
um but of course he is a very strong
player and
he has shown that he can make comebacks
after after loss even in this match
so yeah it's very difficult
another back obviously there's no rest
for the winners you have the Norway
Masters coming up first of all are you
going to celebrate in any way or is it
right back to work and second of all how
excited are you to face off once again
against Magnus Carlson in your upcoming
tournament
um I think I will just uh start just
working I'll just start concentrating
into four Norway chess
and uh
yeah it's very a strong tournament it's
obviously uh obviously Magnus plays
there and uh yeah I'm very excited to
play against him
uh yeah I think it will be very
interesting tournament and uh
uh which is very uh interesting games I
believe and
yeah I I tried to prepare my best and
yeah we'll see
and another back you've been camped out
in Norway for the duration of this
tournament it seems to have brought you
luck what have you been doing day to day
how have you been preparing have you
been going out as well
yeah I was uh just preparing for the
norwich's obviously and uh
uh
uh and uh okay I I did some work for
this tournament also but it was uh
mostly uh I was concentrating to the
Norway chess and just uh working
every day and uh yeah just walk to
having a walk every day and
just enjoying being here and here is
very beautiful so yeah it's I think uh
very very good to combine uh
preparing and resting here so yeah I'm
enjoying here
yeah and the follow-up question this is
the chess kid cop do you have any tips
for all the chess kids out there how can
they play like you how can they become
such a tactical wizard like you are
um obviously it requires a lot of work
and doing uh exercises doing tactics
every day constantly is very useful to
have a great calculation or tactical
vision
and uh yeah basically you have to
practice it every day and uh
um do your best and I think it will come
with with time that you will have a
better calculation skills and
I I mean it's very important to to
become a strong player so yeah it's part
of uh of improving and
uh it comes with time I think
wow just some amazing advice there by
you know the back and this was your
debut in division one and you won a
Champions chest door event joining
Magnus and Hikaru how does it feel to
now officially become one of the greats
of the tour
um yeah it feels great and this is a
a big big uh opportunity for me to play
against them and uh
to compete in this top level and yeah
it's very pleasing and
I will I will do my best and yeah we'll
see
congratulations a fantastic tournament
the Norwich has starts starting soon
thank you
not available
just incredible that's what the future
looks like wherever he plays he is a
force to reckon with he was the youngest
player in the chess kit cup so it's
interesting how the youngest player
actually won the chesket cup yeah the
youngest player were maybe the most
mature style I was impressed with so
many different things but just a
Repertory of positions that he
understands and is able to play all the
different openings you start to think
he's 48 not 18. just so excited to see
what chess has in store for Notre back
as he somehow continues to get better
and achieve more and more
this
this very hard time to the best players
in the world and what a performance by
him but it's not just him there were a
bunch of other chess kids who give a
very hard time to our very own David
Howell take a look
[Music]
I'm sorry sorry
thank you so much
so with a bit of luck I managed to win
all the chess games it was hard work
though and now the kids
are prepared a special challenge for me
will I survive
that's awesome what's the capital of
Guyana
three times two what's the name of
Zeus's father oh wait
I know this bonus Cronus
muscle or not I will say yes it's
actually not a blossom oh what is it
it's a trace fossil the trace fossil
where's Mount Everest
I don't even know I don't even know
this broke my confidence to the point
where I couldn't even understand some of
the questions what do all the
coordinating conjunctions put in a
certain order spell out I was lost the
biggest country in Africa Egypt
what year did Queen boudica die it was
the last Egyptian
s the mean of 40 40 and 13 211 000
652. what are you talking about 895
[Music]
as I was spiraling down this dark dark
hole I sensed a small piece of hope that
I could cling onto
when is Prince Williams
birthday but not a year not a year
okay it's one in 365 chance I could do
this can I guess the month the day might
be hard no you have to do today okay the
date and months I'll say June sometime
you have to have to put a date oh June
21st
[Music]
is that is correct
oh my God that's one of 350.
for real
this is the big lesson from today is
that I need to go back to school I might
have won the chess but the kids
definitely got revenge well done kids
[Applause]
dude you were so happy at the end I'm so
happy I got like one question out of a
million but uh yeah either way those
were the loveliest kids I've ever met
and uh clearly I need to go back and
join them in school so thanks kids and
Shout Out keep up with the chess as well
I'll be back sometime
that's the message for all the chess
kids out there and one just kid of
course who's super happy today is not a
backup this Art Shop he is the winner of
the chess kit cup and we've got Simon
back in the studio Simon we've got other
division winners as well
yeah that's right just a quick update of
all the divisions and I I never realized
that David was a secret Prince Sir
William fan either so he he claims to
Guess that day I just don't believe him
genuinely one out of 365 I I think he's
got posters of Prince William all around
his bedroom really but
[Music]
and two we had a very big victory from
fedexv or big fish on chess.com he's a
regular on chess.com he plays in the
title Tuesday competitions and he won
the Armageddon game actually
surprisingly because he had a very bad
position there but showing his Online
skills and uh I think as Daniel was
saying uh FedEx is is just a quality act
he's had brilliant results in the past
and it'll be great to see him move up to
division one and he's also got ten
thousand dollars in his pocket and
division three the winner of division
free uh if we move over there was
someone who's dominated it throughout
maybe not well certainly not one of the
favorites and I would never have uh put
my money on Alan pischo before but he's
uh he's been uh he's been dominating and
he's he's played an amazing chess for
out and he's a very deserved winner
um so I hope to see him move up some
divisions and show his class and the
other divisions as well so uh those are
the winners and it's been a lot of fun
it's been tremendous fun division one
division two division three we've got
all the winners a big congratulations to
another back to Federal Sav and to Alan
Fisher we saw fantastic chess all around
and going into division going into leg
four off the tour these will be our
standings it is Hikaru Nakamura at the
top after his win in the chassisable
masters with 270 and we see not a back
has joined the top players there with
200 points a huge win in division two in
the trustable Masters and then division
one of the chess kid cup and tour points
are critical for the players to make it
to the season finals so far three spots
have been booked by Hikaru Magnus and
not a back
Daniel a fantastic performance there and
with that they also take home big bucks
and there we see another bag of the
central with forty thousand dollars with
a big win of 57 000 500 that's a pretty
good paycheck there
Daniel this is your first time in the
studio we have a new winner in the
Champions Chester did you have fun I had
a great time obviously uh I enjoyed
watching this from the comfort of my own
home but to be a part even a small part
of the overall machine that makes this
whole production run this incredibly
amazing professional production with the
best go commentators I had a blast and
also I will definitely be back if I'm
invited Daniel we're so excited to have
you back in the studio and it's been
just an amazing incredible tournament
James what was the highlight for you oh
the Highlight was the games I mean you
can learn so much from these games if
you're watching from home or wherever
you're watching look try to take
something from every game it's like free
lessons in a way and I know I'm getting
better just from watching every time
love it
and David you have been so amazing
throughout the tour and I want to ask
you before we say bye to all the chess
kids out there what would you like to
say to them I'd just like to say uh keep
up the good work with the chess keep
going and uh yeah if you ever want to
test me in the general knowledge quiz
you know where to find it
on that note chat it's been amazing what
a tournament and not a bag of do such
Rob is the winner of the chess kit cup
and we will be back with the fourth stop
on the tour in July we'll see you then
we're in a working game where it might
be whoa
A3 jeez Big Fellas Friday man oh my
goodness okay this is the craziest
position I think we've seen on the tour
this season
[Music]
wins the chest
thank you
[Music]
foreign
box
[Music]
ES